[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
today
more than ever when the world comes
together to create a better tomorrow
it's going to be magic oh
Magic
connect with music with architecture
with colors magic with celebration with
your safety From Here There and
Everywhere for six homos day and night
join the making of a new world starting
October 1st
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
has never lost on his birthday but will
he get the W as we move into day four of
the feed a World Chess Championship all
I know is everyone's going to be pumped
at the end of today because today the
main event begins and that is the world
Hess Championship here we go
[Music]
guys I was here Robert
is here no way it's here dude hold on
hold on
and boom
we did it yeah baby it is the world Hess
Championship
that's what I'm talking about this one
has the copyright C what is that Danny
but you get it go look at it look at it
you'll see you'll see here there's a few
others
here I want that one you see it Bobby
you get it now you see it no I have no
idea what no his face there's missing
C's all right
Robert you want to explain it you know
my name the game you play It's called
chess right and there's no word
Championship it's Championship so
there's a c you know
yeah yeah no
I mean I think it's I think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this I don't think
anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest you've ever
seen in my life
well holy
you think it's too late to send it back
I ordered a lot
[Music]
this is day one of the world Hess
championship and boy are we excited to
have you with us we are going to dive
into all the action do what we do on
every pre-game show but first I have to
welcome
my amazing guests here the one and only
the reigning and only world has Champion
Robert how you doing
I'm doing great today it's a special day
I have to say this is one of your more
brilliant ideas and I'm glad the day has
come I cannot wait to see uh how the
world has Champion performs today we're
gonna break down the world has Champions
moments and moves throughout uh Favi
your thoughts on the beginning of the
world has championship
oh guys where's my shirt you said you
didn't want one yeah Danny I was just
with you well geez
foreign
okay well I guess we'll maybe we'll get
Bobby and sure tomorrow if they're not
all sold out by then but uh obviously
you can get yours today and I personally
like the copyright C because don't ever
say chess when you're not allowed to
just say Hess all right we uh we got a
lot to talk about as we get set for game
four here but as always we want to
remind you of what happened in game
three here is chess.com's highlight reel
and dramatic fashion all the amazing
moments that were the last game before
the first rest day
it's time to look ahead to game three
this is awesome I mean this is showing
maybe so far the best showing of opening
prep from Beyond in the match
I'm a bit worried for Magnus now because
he made a move we didn't expect he
played Bishop to C8
[Music]
this Marshall Gambit has a huge amount
of games in theory but it's no longer
very popular because white has run out
of ideas after tens of thousands of
games
[Music]
Magnus would be wise not to trade both
hair rooks unless he sees definitively
it's a draw it likely is a drug
his preparation really held up and that
will make
Beyond try to search for something that
he can that he can put pressure on
magazine in the remaining games
[Music]
hope you enjoyed that recap we continue
to bring him to you in dramatic style
you can check them out on our YouTube
channel reminder we are also live to
Twitch youtube.com chesscom live
launching our new channel specifically
for our live streams head over there and
hit subscribe to make sure that you
don't miss any of our shows that in the
future may be live only to that channel
because when you're producing as much
content as we are sometimes you got to
think about that sort of stuff so
another channel to subscribe to but you
definitely don't want to miss the shows
and events happening at our youtube.com
chesscom live Channel
all right guys let's remind everybody
before we get thoughts and get into the
pregame who's joining us today today on
the other side of the of the hour when
the game ends we will have vitagujrathi
bringing our our special chess guest
given his thoughts as a super Grand
Master the one and only Harry Mack the
guy that's been bringing us these
amazing freestyle raps about both the
Challenger the champion and of course
the event itself and as always we will
be joined by Hammer Hammer bringing the
heat from Norway like he does so okay
it's time to do what we do we're getting
set for game four we have now done all
we can to talk about game three we are
still winless or lossless however you
want to talk about it right let's dive
into the pregame predictions first uh
Fabi you go first on who you think is
going to win the world has Championship
I think Robert's going to win the world
has Championship really it's going to be
close
I think it's not going to be very close
I think Robert's going to crush it okay
well I'll give my predictions and say
that I think it is going to be a close
battle I think it's gonna there's gonna
be some back and forth
um at times we're going to be wrestling
with which has Champion is really the
best but in the end Robert will also win
the Hess Championship yeah Robert wow
well I like the optimism come from you
too
Robert
also by default so I'm in for it okay so
let's dive into the actual predictions
now as we as we talk about Magnus
Carlson getting the white pieces on the
other side of the rest day right this is
a big story line his second chance with
the first move Robert your thoughts on
what the world champion will will have
in store today yeah well it's always
difficult to play on your birthday but
Magnus has never lost as you mentioned
and I do think with the white pieces
he's shown great preparation in his
black games in particular in round two
with white he was in danger because he
missed a pretty natural response by Yan
I think here in game four he's well
rested he's playing well I think matters
Carlson wins okay so we have a
prediction by Robert that the Magnus the
Magnus head as I see before me the world
champion will get the W Bobby
yeah I think Magnus is going to take
today I feel like the last uh few games
Beyond hasn't really been he's been a
bit uh passive in his approach and uh
and I feel he's going to be under
serious pressure today and especially
the rest day
um gives white the extra Edge in
preparation so I think Magnus will come
we already saw in game two that he had a
very interesting opening idea in the
catalog very aggressive sacrificing upon
I think we might see something similar
like that today okay not in the same
opening but an aggressive approach and
I'm predicting Magnus win well I'm
surprised when the three of us agree
especially when it wasn't necessarily
planned but I also believe that Magnus
Carlson is going to win today I believe
that the the storyline that is when will
we have a classical game and decisively
ends today right like Neo says when he
looked at Mr Smith It Ends Tonight right
now I think Magnus Carlson is ready and
I think he's gonna gonna put put that
storyline to rest today and get the W at
the end of the day now we also usually
like to predict our first moves on the
board let's quickly do that on our board
brought To Us by house of Staunton we
thank them so much remember you can get
10 off right now if you're looking for a
great holiday gift for uh for anybody or
just for yourself treat yourself uh go
go and use the promo code chess.com at
go.chess.com Robert I'm going to let you
suggest you are the reigning world has
Champion so I'm gonna let you tell us
the move you think is going to come
first well I don't think E4 will be move
one okay will we see a troll though is
the question I think we might see a
troll but I'm gonna go with D4 again I
like the position of magazine able to
get from that opening I think he'll test
you on once more Bobs I just called you
fobs new nickname let's do it not not
exactly new
Petersfield has been calling that me
that since I was like 14 years old okay
first time I've ever heard of but go
ahead yeah I actually gave this some
thought because I I wasn't
sure like the first time he was white I
was thinking D4 is very likely yep
um now he's already seen neon's
intentions or not to play his usual
grunfels he's going for 906 E6 but he
doesn't know what he's going to play
after instead of the catalog Knight of
three
um E5 Knight C3 E4 Knight F6 wait 93 oh
no sorry D4 on the first move okay
Knight F6 yeah for E6 yeah Knight F3 D5
okay and Knight C3 he doesn't know
yawn's intentions here this is a big
moment yeah so I think either we will
see this and he will try to to see what
Jan wants here and poke and proud of it
or I'm expecting either this or E4 and
he's trying to see Young's intentions
after E4 but I'm going to go with this
instead okay well and you predicted in
in on day two I remember that we might
have a ragosan and if this happens on
the board we might see a ragosan as as
you were thinking with Bishop to B4 or
maybe something more traditional with
Bishop E7 well the other thing is maybe
the reason that uh Magnus is not going
for this is there's a line with C5 here
right away C5 in this position yeah
we'll see take D5 C takes D4 and not to
get too deep into it but yeah if Magnus
thinks there's no Advantage here like
many people do these days then he might
just not enter the territory at all
that's also a possibility so so I guess
we'll see
hard to follow up the specific chess
predictions you guys gave so I'm just
gonna go with the obvious and say that I
also believe we will have D4 on the
board and I'm also going to say that
apparently I've been wrong this whole
time and it's 15 off of these House of
Stuntin boards so again you can you can
use the promo code chess.com and get 15
off so okay well coming up we have round
four just under just about to get
underway we will have the first moves on
the board so we no longer need to try to
predict what's going to happen don't go
anywhere when we come back the players
will be getting sat getting their seats
ready uh probably Yawn is already there
getting it warm he's been doing that
before every game and when we return we
will have the first move of game four of
the feed 8 World Chess Championship
chess.com coverage brought to you by
coinbase
foreign
[Music]
Championship under 35 years that's
craziness been going down since 1886
match format with 14 games many queens
won't be captured the keys will be slain
check out the way I'm unraveling the
Rhymes this is sure to be a true battle
of the mind just so it don't remain a
mystery I'll take a moment to walk you
through the history I said we gotta show
love to the masses 27 years strong
that's Emmanuel Alaska this next name
here is the honor said it's the end game
master Jose Copa Blanca can't forget
Alexander alicon hey yo it's technique
man just my style of rhyme why is that
well he's a master of the tag and I'm
the master for causing disaster over
trash but when he died who's gonna be
the next leader feed day came with the
three year features Soviet Reign for 24
years Cold War pressure in Addison fear
incomes the American Bobby Fisher they
had to get the crown I'm just painting
the picture I'd be in the shadow
straight blasting off I'll be slagging
my rivals like casparov when they come
to spitting sign I'm about to get it
done won't stop till my rate in 28.51 uh
I'm getting loose with the style that
was the past let me take it to the now
coming off top with the clever words
time to introduce the first competitor
if you don't know this is the reminder
the end game magician Norwegian grinder
Triple Crown win to go hard for him of
course I'm talking about Magnus Carlos
saying Izzy the goat the greatest son
highest score ever 20 day 81 can anybody
test the crown well I guess so I mean if
anyone can do it then it's nepho cause
he's never been the one to be give it up
dog beyond the time to see the ill
Russian the one that's causing the
concussion people pay attention from the
moment that he's touching the First Pawn
making the move this Dynamic intuitive
the way he's doing it yeah gonna be an
exciting challenge nippo about to kiss a
game of balance going down 20 21 to do
by chess.com we're gonna keep it two
live twitch exclusive so keep it live we
got Fabiano Carolina up in the spot my
man Robert has and Daniel Rancher yo the
gameplay guaranteed to be intense feed
day Chess Championship it's on keep it
locked right here at chess.com peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
[Music]
thank you
Mike Klein here with chess.com coming to
you at the conclusion of the round three
press conference now following round two
Magnus went on a Norwegian podcast and
he said something to the effect of he
was expecting a stale game today after
all of the excitement of the first two
rounds and that's basically what we got
after a little bit of opening Nuance
just after the game I talked with
napomishi and before we got set up he
actually had a bead of sweat coming down
his forehead but it's not really fair to
say that Magnus caused it I think it was
just the walk from the stage to the
Press area but what about the public
press conference today was a much
different tenor than yesterday maybe
because it's the shortest game that
they've played so far the players got a
little bit more jovial as the press
conference went on you know sometimes a
Magnus has asked questions he can just
kind of mail it in when he doesn't want
to answer but sometimes when he takes
that pause he's thinking of something
very witty to say and that did happen a
couple of times today I asked Magnus how
could the world championship become a
little bit more exciting he's always
kind of leaned more on the side of sport
Less on the side of Science and he said
it should be inherently a combination of
rapid and classical not just rapid as a
means of breaking the tie in case of a
classical what about Yan he was asked
that he had just got done playing one of
the most accurate games in chess history
but he noted there's a doping control
and made a little bit of joke that those
two events are not actually correlated
they're just kind of randomly occurring
together I'm sure that the amount of tea
he drank today is not going to affect
his doping control and lastly what will
the players do on the off date well
Magnus loves sports but this is the
first world championship in a long time
where the water is warm enough a little
bit above 80 degrees Fahrenheit so
really all we want to know is he going
to stay on land or is he going to do
some water sports we'll ask him when we
come back from the rest day round four
starts in two days
the world best championship
[Music]
the champion Robert Hess
the Challenger Robert Hess
watch the only twitch broadcast with
Robert Hess on chess.com TV your home
for the World Air championship
oh so good we had no idea that was
coming oh my God thank you team thank
you
I had no idea that we did that video
that was the best that was the best
makes so much more sense because they
were asking me to do like weird things
like save my name so they could record
it but I have no idea what it was for I
was like it was like a testing thing and
now here we go that was amazing it's not
every day most the time we're the ones
trying to bring surprises for you uh
viewers but today our team our team got
us there so thank you that that was
awesome
um all right uh we were gonna react to
Mike's video I don't even know what to
react to anymore uh so so great
um the rest day we will find out what
the players did thank you Mike for that
update and uh
well I don't even know where to go it
threw me up okay let's let's talk about
our predictions in terms of what we did
we all predicted Magnus would win and um
that's
maybe surprising maybe not right we all
kind of have a similar sort of storyline
getting the white pieces after a rest
day
um you know getting getting another
chance to see what his team could come
up with uh before we I want to get more
thoughts on you guys where you guys are
at but let me remind everybody that they
should head over to chess.com and vote
on what they think should happen as you
saw we believe that it's Magnus taking
the day today but you can go to
chess.com events and cast your vote it's
very easy our moderators will share a
direct link to do so and again one of
the things to remind everybody is yes if
you've been playing along maybe you're
one of the few hundred that are still
perfect but there are prizes being given
away every day so you should play even
if you didn't start on day one we're
giving away Diamond memberships every
single day just for playing along all
you have to do is head over to chess.com
events and let's remind everybody of
what's at stake three thousand dollars
for first place someone's taking home
three grand in cash just for casting
their vote at chess.com events and if
you go with what we predicted I'm Magnus
win and you're right you might be
separating yourself from the pack today
but but we'll see about that so yeah
let's let's add um very very quickly
your thoughts again on why you feel like
today's the day of the world champion
not not just because it's his birthday
but maybe no I think playing on your
birthday is actually bad for your chest
but what's interesting when I was
thinking about this is Magnus actually
the biggest disadvantage of the entire
match in game two with the white pieces
that said if we ignore the middle let's
go back to the start he had an advantage
of the opening it was his type of
position and John could have been in
grave danger had Magnus played a little
more accurately fobby I'm going to ask
you to hold your thoughts for when the
first one today we have to take one more
very quick break when we come back it
looks like the players are already
getting set so when we return you will
see them at the board you will hear
fobby's thoughts even more context on
why we're all unanimously predicting
that the world champion finds his finds
his form in classical for the first time
in five years takes home the dub on his
birthday don't go anywhere we will be
right back with game four coverage of
the 2021 feed a World Chess Championship
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the first move of the event the
president of fide arcade devorkovic
and a special guest making the first
move
his Excellency the
General Secretary of the Dubai Sports
Council once again his Excellency Syed
Hare
because Excellency will make the first
move for Magnus Carlson
happy birthday
and with that let the game begin
and it looked ooh was it C4 I will find
out oh Fabi was so for those who don't
know I'm gonna give Bobby credit he gave
us a long variation what oh my gosh
Bobby during the break Bobby's like I
regret saying that whole line in D4 I
think he's gonna play E4 yeah
but what is going on with the trolling
here well we didn't did we see if uh he
gave him the first movie because it
didn't look like they spoke it looked
like he just made a move I'm not sure
what they're sometimes the the person
who makes the first move sorry
interruptify but look at the opening I
know somebody who may be one of the
world's renowned theoreticians in the
Petrov and we have a Petrov does that
shock you because I'm a bit surprised to
see yondu but I was thinking about
mentioning two yesterday during the day
off it wouldn't be funny if Jan took one
from yearbook yeah Robert and I
discussed this yesterday and
um I I thought that the most logical
opinion Freon would be to play the
Berlin that seemed like a natural choice
for him in case Magnus were to play E4
but Petrov is interesting I really
didn't expect this well I mean you
played it so successfully in your 2018
uh world championship bout and uh it
some of your some of your best chances
came with the black pieces in in the
Petrov right everyone remembers the
Infamous game six
I
I I'm a little stunned I'm so glad we
have Fabiano caruana here Robert because
we're about to we're about to have a
show where nobody is going to know more
about you just have to be careful not to
reveal too much prep Bobby because
they're going to be in variations where
everyone knows you are you are the man I
will I will not uh oh so this is
um somebody has played D4 D5 this is on
the board I guess Bishop D3
is the most likely move uh
Bishop D3 has been played I see and now
I think Jan will probably play Bishop D6
this is like this is the Refuge for
black in this line now yeah
um
it's it's super theoretical and just
it's very direct black is just copying
White's moves now White Castles black
castles
white plays C4 black plays C6 and then
white has a wide choice of moves okay so
one thing we can always predict is a
small dgt relay error but it corrected
itself very fast that was nice so C4 C6
go ahead and this is the interesting
moment okay um this will all happen
almost for sure
um and now White's main moves are rookie
one Queen C2
um those are the two main moves and
Knight C3 is also a very
very popular move
um let's say as a third main move and
the old Main Line like when this was
popular back in the 90s
everyone played cd5 cd5 Knight C3 but
that's gone out of fashion because black
doesn't
um
really face any problem theoretical
problems there okay so it'll be
interesting to see what Magnus picks
because all these moves are like rookie
one Queen C2 all Knight C3 all these
moves are
um considered to be okay for black in a
theoretical sense
but uh
but it's not easy for black and any of
them like rookie one is the move I face
most when I play this line uh everyone
will play rookie one against me
you said that theoretical advantage or
what's the most challenging
theoretically speaking because what
you've said in previous rounds and what
magnets have shown through his career is
he's not always choosing the most direct
line the most popular line so he's happy
very often to go for something a little
more offbeat that said I'm curious when
you think in the first time he's facing
this Petrov if he will be direct and
then move us away from that in future
games or at this moment here do you
think he could come up with something
that isn't quite topical but is very
Magnus
um I think Magnus already hasn't had an
idea beforehand what he would do in case
the Petrov happened
um he played D4 rather quickly and that
was a big choice for him on move um on
move five yep because he could have
played Knight C3 so he played D4 rather
quickly I assume
this is the main line you consider if
you're if you're going for this with
white uh so I guess he's already you're
you're saying if he was going to show
something different it might have been
right here well there's a it's this is a
big choice between main lines one is D4
one is Knight C3 right and it's a big
debate over which is more of a problem
for black right
um like historically it's been more nice
C3 that's been considered the problem
but then more recently everyone's
playing D4 people kind of shifted away
from Knight C3 so
he's thinking now but of course he has
something in mind in this line yeah well
actually no I think he's moved C4 and
Yawn is Yawn is actually gone from oh
John hasn't played CC yeah
still thinking and still not at the
board so again the uh
the Journey of using our imagination
about whatever they're doing when
they're away from the board continues
here as even in the opening Yawn is is
quickly getting up
um one of the reasons this line was
revitalized for black is after C6
Queen C2 was very often considered a
problem okay let's let's go down as as
far as you want to take us down to
Fabiano caruana Rabbit Hole of
preparation let's do it well I'm not
going to like talk about the theory too
deeply here
um like Knight A6 uh I'm black Black's
had a lot of possible moves 96 was one
of them and there's a huge amount of
theory but then at some point people
started to play after Queen C2 H6
yeah and just in general in this
variation black is pretty happy to give
upon and it's a Central Pawn so you
think that it's kind of
counter-intuitive but with the bishop
pair and especially a quick initiative
against that Queen on e4 you can get
moves like rookie eight and you get a
bunch of Tempe so you get sufficient
compensation for the sacrist pawn
Bobby what do you think is the
compensation sufficient in this line
yeah it's considered pretty sufficient
um
this is this is all all pretty known
stuff uh he it looks like and rookie one
on the board yeah yeah and and this I
mean usually they play Bishop F5 here
um
and then basically white is just trying
black is a little bit
um his pawns are a bit hanging after
let's say queen B3 so this is
this is a large body of Theory actually
I'll just show
um a funny line okay I'll try to
remember it so black plays Queen D7 here
it's not force but okay but the point is
of course C takes D5 cannot be captured
right because I'll just show it at the
end of the line we have Bishop takes H2
check winning the queen
so he uh White can't do that so uh
usually the move is Knight C3
this is more pressure Knight takes C3
Bishop takes a five Queen F5
uh of course white can play bc3 here but
there's also move Queen takes B7
oh
uh Knight to E4 they're not of course
none of this is uh is strictly forced
between A8 uh Queen D7
takes D5
and
um
it's been so long I've looked at this
black has like Knight F6 has a move
interesting like the queen is trapped
but it's it's all about uh tactics to
provide to Save the Queen because for
the moment it's not easy to get that
Queen
um Knight of six is one of the most cd5
is another move
okay even even cd5 still works everyone
because if you take black still has
Bishop takes yeah but here why has Rook
takes E4
okay and Knight C6 black doesn't want to
take the Rook because NY will be up two
pawns Queen A8 I I'm not sure Bishop of
fader we'll play one of them and whites
move Rooks whites Rook sorry moves back
somewhere
black plays like F6
and nominally white is ahead a
significant amount of material two Works
an opponent for the queen but
the Bishops are actually kind of
important Black's Bishop is
significantly better than whites and
actually black is preparing an attack G5
H5 G4 so this would be a very exciting
Line to See this is one approach for
black
or
I I'm saying this because this is sort
of known
known Theory so you're not revealing
anything too special or or after cd5
I've actually played this position with
black against Sergey karyakin okay after
C takes D5 okay and I played Knight to
F6
uh and let me just try to remember this
Theory
um
white has has a rookie three this is
this is how white saves the queen
um if Knight takes D5 Rook B3 and the
queen escapes
uh Knight or
Knight to B4 I I already I'm starting to
forget the line but uh in any case White
Queen White Queen Escapes in black
um tries to equalize in the end it's not
not entirely
easy to equalize for working this line
so wowzers that's all I can say
oh man
I did not think Robert we would have
I did not anticipate a Petrov in this In
This World Chess Championship Match
maybe in the world has Championship I
would have but not in the World Chess
Championship but I'm even more glad that
uh you know that this this Odd Couple
added a third wheel well on one hand
it's shocking because Magnus has
prepared extensively for the Petrov he
did play Fabian on the previous World
Championship but a lot has changed since
then and of course Magnus regularly
prepares for the Petra because other
people play it and you have to be up to
date that's it I think it could be a
good psychological Ploy from Jan okay it
may feel uncomfortable because if you
look through the options of what Jan
could have played I think E5 comes as
expected it of course plays the Sicilian
and plays it quite well but it's risky
to place a stone the general seeing more
tactics at play you could fall victims
some sharp variation and just you know
kind of find yourself lost after the
opening so playing this variation it is
more solid it may allow mag to try to
grind yawn in a longer game but I do
think it's a bit uncomfortable for
Magnus and we see Magnus now sitting and
thinking trying to figure out what to do
I like the choice yeah
we see yawn behind us on our on our
amazing uh live look in here in studio
and now Magnus has made the move Queen
B3 so let's bring let's bring back our
analysis board here because we're we're
two moves further along already yeah I'm
going to this is exactly what Fabiano
caruano I'm going to say the world's
leading expert in the opening we see on
the board predicted I'm not sure I'm
gonna call you that you don't have to go
with it I'm actually going to make a
small prediction because let's say black
doesn't have to play Queen D7 he he also
has um Knight A6 as a move I think is
pretty sensible as well but Queen D7 uh
is probably the most likely choice
and I see and I I think that maybe
Magnus will go for this line Knight C3
okay take the line we looked at after
Bishop 5 Queen F5 but instead of Queen
B7 because he knows Yawn is super well
prepared and queen B7 and it's likely a
bit too forcing bc3 might actually be a
a better choice to get
a playable small Advantage by the way we
have Queen D7 on the board so again uh
all the main lines you're predicting are
are coming to pass let's remind chat now
that now that you've already cast your
vote at chess.com it's time for you to
spam either Magnus or yawn in chat let
us know who you're rooting for we have
an active poll maybe not necessarily who
you're rooting for you can use the
emotes for that but you can also use
your channel points and cast your vote
on what you think the result will be
today so go for it Now's the Time let's
do it all right Bobby
um
I like his prediction obvious yeah no I
think of course he's Fabiano caruana but
from a practical point of view
especially if you're facing a surprise
in this game yeah the most forcing lines
if you haven't studied it recently and
your opponent has that puts you in a lot
right you you might struggle to even
find the way out and as we were just
talking about in that position there's
like a weird rookie three Rook B3 those
ideas don't come very naturally
especially from a distance in the moment
of course mags will find it so I do
think that in the event of Knight C3 and
we see those minor Pieces come off you
can play Safe and Sound chest not that
Magnus just wants to play safe every
game but in the first surprise that he's
facing here it might make sense because
he can try to build an advantage if we
go to that position yeah let's finalize
it we've got so again you want nice C3
yep takes shake and bake but the
difference is bc3 rather than the
forcing Queen for two Brooks sacrifice
what does Black's main move here Bobby
uh here black usually plays B6 you can
also defend upon Queen D7 but it's a bit
of an awkward
way to do it because your knight one
actually goes to D7 but you're kind of a
and Robert you're saying this is this is
a line vintage Magnus will say right
it's uh it's not the most forcing
especially the first time when we're
when we're they're trying to feel each
other out in terms of the pet drop that
may not have been predicted this is more
of a small grinded out Edge for white it
is and John of course is prepared for
this as well you don't play this if you
haven't thought deeply about what your
response would be but I do believe in
that position white has the Pawns in the
center right so that is a a nice thing
for white and Advantage we want more
Pawns in the center especially with
pieces on the board because that pawn on
D4 and we see B takes D3 the pawn on D4
limits where those pieces can go I say
this very often upon three squares away
from a knight dominates that night at
night in D7 that's step one they'll
probably end up going to F6 that takes a
bit of time and the concern that white
might have if white takes on D5 in this
position
yes black is saddled with an isolated
Pawn after C takes D5 but just to show
the look of this position there's a pawn
C3 that's a backward Pawn you do have a
dark Square Bishop that can defend that
pawn but you don't want your Bishop to
be sitting on b or D2 simply protecting
you want to be a little bit more
aggressive and black on the other hand
can bring the Knight via C6 to A5 take
over the light squares and guess what
White's gonna have a tough time
defending those light squares because
white has a dark Square Bishop so I
think that this could give black some
chances as well not just white even if
we do agree that white would have a
slight Edge at the beginning I don't
think C takes D5 you don't want to
include that too soon
okay Bobby yeah yeah I wanted to go a
bit deeper into what Robert said which
is absolutely correct that the structure
is um potentially uh a big week for both
sides so let's say after B6 cd5 which
white at some point should play dd5 uh
White actually wants to trade Queens
here which is what's the difference that
the Queens are off
um
well it's a bit like what Black's Bishop
is aiming at White's King I mean Black's
King looks like the safer one between
the two
um and end games surprisingly white is
the one with the better chances because
that D5 Pawn is more of a weakness than
C3 and so let's say white plays Queen to
B5 here which I I think might actually
happen uh Queen to D7
uh because Knight D7 is tactically
uh yeah there's a bit hanging let's say
after Queen to C6
Bishop his in serious trouble that's so
funny in the middle of the board the
bishop is
crap because the queen can go to protect
him when you lose a knight yeah so here
black loses this is so optically
pleasing I don't know that's a weird
thing to say but this is like the bishop
can't go to any square and if it goes to
B8 you lose well you don't actually lose
the Rook because of the check well
there's Bishop A3 coming in and okay it
does end up being being lost for blood
wow okay this is amazing so black plays
Queen to D7 and this is White's Point
that he's sort of forcing the Queen's
Right uh White takes takes white can
play let's say A4 at some point it's
just useful to let's say get some space
on the queen side uh and if black
attacks the C3 pawn it looks like that's
a bit of a weakness but white can simply
Play Bishop to D2
and White's plan is to bring the king to
D3
King F1 E2 D3 and then the Knight Will
maneuver itself because black actually
doesn't have much counter play to E3
usually it'll go via E1 white will play
G3 ooh or you can go via H4 G3 Knight H4
Knight G2 E3 and a D5 Pawn
um the surprising thing is that
sometimes we think about good Bishops
because they're not on the color complex
of the let's say weak Pawn but sometimes
upon if it can be defended by a bishop
right it gives more of a weakness
um and in this case if white black had a
dark a light a bishop on light squares
then that pawn would no longer be
weakness because it couldn't really be
attacked but this way that pawn is
forced basically to be defended by a
knight or by rook and by Rook is very
awkward so it so probably by a knight
which means at that point is a serious
weakness
if we imagine very long-term plans like
King to D3 Knight coming to E3 and white
can play Rook ew1 Rook to B5 that pawn
is actually a serious a very serious
long-term weakness so this kind of
um position and we saw Queen B5 on the
board
uh this this position is
is a bit better for white it's not a
disaster or anything but uh but we're
we're getting exactly what you predicted
on the board and my apologies for going
full Hikaru there chat never go full
Hikaru but really wanted to highlight
all of the plans that Fabiano was
bringing us because this is deep stuff
and it's fascinating stuff and
educational stuff to really be able to
look at a position like this recognize
the long-term weaknesses and look at all
of your pieces with a with a clear path
right they all have a purpose and a goal
and this is but I mean so Bobby here we
are we are we are in the position as you
predicted the Queens will be coming off
so are you I mean this is fun for you
right we talk a lot about how when all
of us watch the world championship it
changes theory in in certain lines it's
when all this deep prep that you guys
have been working on is showed to the
rest of the world as one of their peers
do you get excited when you see them
playing a line that you kind of know
well and you're like all right I'm gonna
I want to see what they cooked up here
well yeah uh so he he played A4 okay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I think black can take with either
Knight or Rook
um and then the Knight goes to C7 and
that's a good defender of the D5 pawn
and usually black equalizes pretty
comfortably here and so in a line like
this the B6 pawn and C3 pawns sort of
cancel each other out as far as
weaknesses go yeah in this case I think
white is hurt a little bit by the fact
that the a pawns were traded off because
that means the Rooks will be traded off
and that starts to diminish his winning
capacity but Knight H4 is really
fascinating I I uh I didn't know this
this move I I suspect
um
well Jana's starting to think he might
know this move but he is starting to
think a bit here uh so it's probably an
excellent opening idea for myself I mean
look at this everybody we might have our
first first novelty in in the Petrov and
as as Fabiano himself says this is not a
move you've looked at right and also
look it passes your criteria of It kind
of initially says Black's a little
better which suggests to me there's a
decent possibility yawn might not have
looked at this line too deeply right
yeah and I think what Fabiano is saying
all has obvious Merit and it's that
exact thing where also the depth of the
engine matters where the players they
have their super computers they're
working day in day out trying to find
the best lines if you have a passing
glance at the position let me say oh
black is quite a bit better there you
mean what we saw before it was actually
as a protective passport then point two
it's actually going down the more it
thinks so something to note is the
long-term weaknesses of Black's position
if you go back just before Knight H4 to
taking ampa song in addition to oh on
the sun okay in addition to having the
Rooks being traded black can defend the
D5 Pawn with the Knight on C7 oh yeah
whether it's Rook takes the system
Knight takes A6 the point is the Knight
can safely defend the pawn but if you go
to the game position well after Knight
H4
where is that Nike to defend D5 from
you're probably gonna bring your knight
to F6 and if you're gonna go Knight F6
you
yep so you know the point is that when
the Knight does get to F6 in the game
the bishop can try to come to G5 and
kick the Knight away so that means you
might play H6 for black to stop Bishop
G5 at some point but if you play H6 you
can't play G6 next so that means the
Knight Will secure the F5 Square so
essentially black is able to stop one
move or the other but not both at least
not very easily and that can give white
very rapid play yeah I didn't mean HX of
force in the immediate position but as a
long-term idea whether you want to push
your kingside pawns you're not going to
be able to push both
no it's fascinating because you're again
just to summarize if you
if you stop the night from coming into
F5 your dark squares are weaker and
probably this plan of bringing the
Knight to to F6 is always met by Bishop
G5 taking away the key defender of the
week D5 Pawn which is where the Knight
is headed whether it finds that Square
via F5 E3 or G3 and then G2 E3 so the
whole point is black
has to make a choice here right you're
kind of choosing between poisons about
how to defend your D5 Pawn long term
yeah I think that here black has
basically two logical moves one is 97
one is G6 because White's idea at the
moment is knighted to F5 yep um if white
we're given a free move here Knight of
five just wins the bishop can't be
comfortably defended it has to go back
and then black starts to lose material
with Knight of seven and other other
yeah little four coming to G7 there so
97 it looks like at first it doesn't
solve that issue after Knight F5 black
has Rook F to E8
exploiting the back rank issues and also
very importantly opening a square for
the bishop to drop back to f8 and then
let's say we see like Bishop D2 here
uh maybe not the best move but after
Bishop f8 Knight E3 black is also ready
for Knight F6 defending that pawn and it
looks like black has solved all of his
um immediate uh tactical issues
interesting if we backtrack just a bit
there at The Rook E8 which is such a
nice move to clear the square attack
through can we play Bishop G5 instead of
uh Bishop to D2 because Bishop G5 takes
away Knight F6 as your next move and
your Bishop now is under attack on D6 so
I I wonder if that's the difference is
in a line like this bishop f8 93 this
Pawn is yeah
uh
this Pawn is a problem yeah because
you'd have to play H6 G5 but then you're
at risk of overextending and you
permanently give white the F5 Square for
the Knight right once your pawns go
forward they can't go back and then also
Bishop to E5 here is another issue but I
think black is really helped by trading
Rooks
um one pair of Rooks first of all
because black has is only one with the
past Pawn at the moment so Rooks are the
best defenders behind past pawns
um this helps black get rid of that
problem and now Bishop f8s
um
and I also wonder about 97 it's also a
question because of the Rook convey
invades yep but uh then we have to ask
ourselves questions like let's say 97
take Rook takes what about A4 Rook D7 A3
uh oh uh I I would be very worried for
what I'm gonna leave that one to the
imagination for chat every once in a
while you got to do that yeah have them
solve them have them solve the a pawn
problem well I think we could uh point
out in that line after A4 Rook D7 A3 if
white at H3 this would actually be fine
for white we're not actually just
winning because white would play Bishop
to C1 A2 Bishop to B2 but the bank back
rank issue makes itself felt white gets
checkmated so that great problems
everybody got them everybody got him
okay
um
by the way G6 looks like it's on the
board indeed it as
yeah John has committed
committed the pawn to G6 to stop the
knight from coming into F5 so Bobby
oh man Bobby oh man
now John John played it he didn't take
too much time there so you're oh wow and
then G4 just comes instantly for the
world champion really Flex in here this
is yeah this is beautiful stuff this is
beautiful stuff regardless of what
happens I mean it makes your I can feel
you over there you're a little tingly
don't get to it I mean I was thinking
the most natural move was G3 because you
want to get that Knight to E3 uh but
this has the additional benefit of well
how does black defend D5 it's with the
Knight on F6 yeah this Pawn comes to G5
it kicks the night out so let's say
black plays Knight D7 okay I think white
will play Knight to G2 okay and let's
say black plays Knight F6 yeah instead
of Knight E3 I actually think white can
play F3
uh slowly that night will eventually get
kicked out well Robert always says upon
three squares away dominates a pony
yeah it dominates that night for sure
and you also in this line keep the G5
score open for both the pawn and the
bishop that's exactly right
wow oh my gosh I see the uh evaluation
bar is severely unhappy with White's
position so maybe F3 was not the right
move yeah but maybe this is I mean it's
severely unhappy is relative based on
everything that you've said this whole
time right you gave this incredible
answer that at the chat if you missed
day two's answer to how Fabi approaches
engine prep you're going to want to find
that highlight talking about positions
like this the point to summarize is it
says Black's a little better that's
exactly the kind of position you look
for when trying to out Trick and out out
out I'll maneuver your opponent although
if we just take one half move back
before F3 maybe white could play Bishop
F4 that's not out of the question
because I'm willing to give up the G4
Pawn to get your D5 pawn and if I then
play yeah here I'm gladly taking on D5
and the position falls apart but if you
I'm going with Bobby to play F3 next I'm
just trying to wonder is the bishop
trade helpful for white is it helpful
for black on one hand
it allows black to more easily defend D5
but on the other that bishop1c1 it
wasn't clear exactly where it would go
so trading it off does make sense
because the bishop on D6 was Black's
best piece so this kind of type position
we see some squares for the Rook to get
into without the bishop on D6 The Rook
can get to E7 now of course black is
gonna stop that but these size positions
remain interesting and it just sometimes
good to see with our eyes pieces off the
board so then we can determine do we
want that trade we have the benefit of
doing that the players do not so this
type of position whether or not the
Bishops are on the board
it makes a big difference and the
players need to figure that out
yeah I also think maybe the idea after
Knight D7 I was I was thinking about
this for a second main line here is uh
is possibly G5 right away right away uh
black needs to get that nine to play
it's right now the Knight has no future
it cannot go the D4 pawn stops those
squares the G5 pawn stops Knight F6 and
the B5 pawn stops 96 A6 and all those
the Knight is limited by White's pawns
which means you want to get rid of that
G5 Pawn uh the problem is let's say you
try to play F6 Rook E6 comes and uh
starts to cause massive advocate in
Black's position
um so so black maybe has some concrete
issues with getting this Knight into
play Maybe H6 you can always do this
but the thing is just sacrifice the pawn
straight up
wait a second sorry after the main line
so Knight D7 G5 H6 I'm thinking that
white doesn't want to take that pawn
because that pawn is easily controlled
by the King on H7 and will at some point
get lost maybe I just wants to play F4
um it's basically white is doing
anything to try to keep that Knight out
of the game
uh but
looks like we have Knight D7 delivered
from Dubai special delivery from Dubai
we have Knight D7
and that G5 F4 line does look like white
could be engage of overextending because
you permanently give all of your light
squares to Black so yeah I I feel like
depending how quickly Magnus plays you
know of course he's still within the
realm of his preparation and look at
this right as you say it this is just
Knight G2 he's he's on path I I
obviously we're super impressed with
magnus's prep and I can't wait to see
where this goes but I'm also kind of
impressed with how quickly John's been
responding I guess I mean he doesn't
feel
super out of his depth yet or do you
think these moves are just logical
enough that he's kind of keeping it
hidden that maybe he's a little worried
about just how just how deep the world
champions home cooking is here well he
may have also checked us we we can't
know for sure yeah that yeah he looks
like he's thinking and he's a bit out of
uh his knowledge but it's possible that
this has also been checked by him and
his team uh but it's clear that
magnus's prep so far has been excellent
in every game he's been prepared well
into the middle game
um here I I assume that he will also be
prepared for several moves down the road
I don't think that he will because black
has very limited options here but beyond
playing Rick fc8 so quickly kind of
makes me think that also he he knows
this position because you you don't play
instantly yeah unless you know it I mean
it's it's not in a position where moves
comes so easily you know Knight F6 was a
supernatural move it was our first yep
Instinct for all of us I think and and
then we're FCA instantly played it's a
natural move but you know I think you
stop and think unless you actually know
this yeah especially because this is
this is exactly the type of dangerous
position against Magnus where you stop
and think because where these pieces put
themselves super important right this is
a maneuvering game where you might put
your piece on a wrong square and have
consequences five moves later yeah that
cost you you also can't take this back
because if Knight E3 now yeah Knight F6
is gonna be met by G5
so you are giving up the D5 Pawn for the
C3 pawn and that's a huge decision that
you do not take like like that means
Knight E3 you're saying we're about to
see a trade here oh I don't think that
Knight E3 will be played because after
Rook c395 you won that very important
Pawn but the B6 Pawn is securely
defended right and this d-pawn is is a
bit too so soft
Comes Here Comes Here Comes the alpha
the alpha on the a file pure black would
be better yeah for sure Rook fc8 right
so you're giving up the pawn immediately
but you also are putting your rook in an
odd spot because it's going to be
difficult to defend D5 with all of your
pieces in the queen side now you do have
that past A5 pawn and that's going to be
a serious Thorn and white side but
Magnus chose this variation like they
did so for a reason so I mean so what's
what's the move then if well uh Robert
mentioned the move Bishop F4 before I
think that move is pretty sensible here
okay because after I take or keep well
it's it's a concession for sure to put
your Bishop back because then white
gained an active Bishop compared to
blacks relatively passive Bishop 1 f8
and then Knight E3 actually makes more
sense yeah although I'm still not sure
it's so good
um but it makes more sense than me than
the previous move
um but this this would definitely be a
plus even if white just plays Bishop D2
because the bishop is better on D6 on f8
uh so after Bishop before I assume that
black would take
and
and here that Rook takes C3
it starts to get sharp Knight D5 black
has various moves like Rook
uh but I don't know well the thing is
that after any move Rook E7 is coming so
you have to deal with that threat
um
it's actually a difficult threat yeah
I'm sitting here like
what
um what do you do I mean do you come
back to guard the night that just feels
like but then in any case over 67 and
Knight F6 Fort town I didn't miss this
everybody I'm just going to show you
this right second check was also a fork
to be okay I just you know I just I'm
just showing this for the chat you know
um yeah so I I think after night takes
because it's by the way you're right
Bishop reports on the board it's an
interesting position after 95 I think
that black
will have to attack one of White's Pawns
um like let's say take take
Rook C3 Knight D5
let's just make a movie because it's
difficult to know which move but Rook D3
let's say Rook to E7
Knight to f8 is forced
Knight takes B6 white grabs upon Rook to
B8 and we might actually see a massive
simplification because why is up a pawn
but uh two pawns hanging potentially G4
also hanging a lot of the pawns will get
traded off very very soon
so this looks like if we saw this exact
position this looks like it's heading
towards a draw
but uh I guess that after
Knight takes D5 Rook D3 Magnus still has
something in mind
yeah I'm also curious
um
in the start of the position right with
Bishop F4
and if we trade on F4 and I know I'm
backtracking a little bit but can we
just play Knight F6 and invite G5 and
then go 94 is that just I guess you just
take on D5 and this is rolling too I
guess I was like trying to take on G5
and 4q on F3 but you're you come first
and more powerfully for white so this is
too many forks too many problems yeah
this is not good of course so yeah back
to the lines we were looking at which
um could be just a big trade but maybe
there's something magazines do to keep
the tension alive in those positions um
I'm wondering after take take Rook C3
Bishop F4 Knight of four Rook C3
I was like briefly wondering about Rook
to E7
immediately right away but actually even
if black plays Knight of Fate a black is
906 but even if Knight of Fate that
doesn't change anything so there's no
advantage
to this whatsoever yeah we're getting
this massive simplification we're
suddenly the G4
pawn and it allows black to extra option
of Knight F6 so I guess all the moves up
to Knight takes D5 are forced
um or close enough to force that we can
comfortably predict them because and
you're still saying there's no merit to
keeping the bishop on the board well I
think that
you only play Bishop of ADA for some
reason you want to try to beat white
here
but I don't see why
like this this feels like white plays a
move like let's say Rook e to C1
yeah or even rookie three okay yeah but
yeah I really want that square for my
Knights that's the only reason and then
I play F3 93 and my Bishop 1 F4 is just
super like you'll really struggle to
deal with this D5 Pawn because now the
bishop is free to attack the Knight on
F6
I'm just fighting for pieces to stay on
the board that's what I fight for I
fight for interesting I'm worried about
this forcing line not because you know
we have any dog in the fight but
obviously like everyone else I want
blood yeah I think there are ways for
the pieces to remain on the board but if
White's not careful black is the one
with the outside pass pawn and with the
trade of the D5 Pawn for the C3 Pawn
white spawn structure is worse is it I
said A B Pawn nicely a d-pawn so as we
go through these lines here and the
players are calculating just this in the
event of the trade I am a little curious
about something so
like Rook takes C3 Knight takes D5 and
there's three good looking options for
black right Rook B3 Rook D3 and I would
eliminate Rook C4 as what may initially
look attractive because you're attacking
D4 because Rook E7 there's huge tactical
problems your Rook are actually going to
be forked when the Knight takes on B6 so
we can eliminate Rook C4 but B3 and D3
Rook B3 is not actually a threat in the
at first because Rook text B5 would be
met by Knight C7 so we know that
there's always a fork available for the
White Knight so that does give white
some more options in the position that
said if you take on B6 we're having the
same massive simplification that Fabiano
was talking about where black just plays
Rook to B8 wins the B5 pawn and so I
both lines look at least in the initial
position that black is holding and the
fact that Magnus and Bishop F4 quickly
that leads me to believe that he's still
in his preparation but I'm wondering or
at least maybe not
is Magnus bluffing a little bit he's
playing quickly yeah but the more I
analyze both on the board and in my head
black seems to be looking all right
let's zoom in on Magnus we see he's uh
he's focused Big Town
but is that a
you played you played Magnus so the body
language read Bobby oh he doesn't look
super focused
I mean he's he obviously knows the
position so he's not let's say concerned
at all he um
yeah I'm just wondering because the
position is like
they're getting very simplified and
black has a very obvious way of playing
so the question is really
I think he'll take he'll play Rook c395
and he'll very likely play Rook to D3
the only reason I say Rook to D3 rather
than Rook to B3 is because Rook to B3
actually doesn't thread in rotates B5
[Music]
um because of the Knight C7 Fork
so
so I have to rotate like after working
through the question is what can
magnus's idea be
because I don't think that he just wants
to
instantly go for a draw maybe he's so
surprised by the Petrov that that he
that he didn't know what to do and
sometimes like you said like you're
surprised you're surprised you go for
something what ends up not showing on
the board is a bunch of opportunities
where your opponent could have chosen a
bad line right so you tested something
yeah it didn't work so but the only on
not let's say move where black had more
natural options was Rook F to ca so was
he really counting on one move where
black could have gone wrong because like
g697 these are pretty much
almost automatic moves you know right
even if you don't know the position you
don't know the position yeah you kind of
have to play it well that's what I was
asking you to think about was whether or
not yawn was
playing
playing from prep as well but you feel
like Rook fc8 was played quickly enough
that there's a pretty good chance he
still at least knew something about the
line I I would assume so it was it's it
could also be played over the board it
is I guess a sensible move sensible
enough that
you can think well I want to play Rook
F2 C8 and rather than Rook a to C8 I
want to play the other Rook to avoid
Bishop H6 stuff and
um and to get the bishop Maybe
get it back to f8 potentially
um and to keep the Rook on a behind the
a pawn so that the a pawn can one day
push
um
so I don't know there's a lot of things
all right let's
well if we're thinking about it I mean
yon is now back at at the board
considering how to deal with Bishop
before but you said you just you don't
see anything besides takes here just no
reason to let that Bishop stay active
Robert yeah it seems like that has to be
because Bishop f8 gives white
more opportunities and in this position
I think black is the one who has to be
more concerned because Bishop f8 is a
step back 93 is a step forward taking on
D5 starts attacking all sorts of
different directions yeah sorry rookie
to see one first and then yeah I should
say uh but the thing about this position
is that with the trade of Bishops then
the trade of the C Pawn for the d-pawn
it becomes very simplified so if Yan can
see this through if he can say all right
in all these variations that I'm
analyzing in my head eight moves down
the line I think that black is holding
in all of them I'm trading this Pawn for
that pawn and if the d-pawn in
particular you know gets off the board I
don't see where white could have any
hope the real thing is can white somehow
keep that D4 Pawn try to turn it into a
runner a past Pawn that's actually
marching up the board towards the other
side so and if that even cost you the B5
Pawn that could be worth it but I'm just
trying to figure out how we get to that
because black is the one currently with
that nice outside pass Pawn that you
always got to keep your eye on
okay so so let's just let's just see
what Magnus could do because I'm I'm
trying to think of something for white
after Rook D3 and this position Rook E7
I don't see any move
besides rookie seven I had a crazy idea
that there was a different approach that
justified the G pawns advance and I
obviously it just it seems silly to
believe that there was any idea here but
if I could have Knight F6 and G5 and D5
maybe but I can't I can't yeah Knight F6
check okay King G7 98 check oh Sheboygan
now and if you go there now D5 so this
is actually what I was thinking about
okay starting my little monologue there
I was hoping if you're playing for a win
that you have this exact scenario black
has a protected outside Pawn but White's
Pawn on D5 is protected people think
what are you talking about Rook can take
it but there's always this Fork on F6 or
C7 that will win you material and you
mentioned G5 G5 could lead to a mating
next exact positions so that's actually
quite scary and white pieces are
dominating blacks pieces particularly
the the knights the nine f8 is very
passive for now the 9 E8 is doing
wonders for White's chances and this
could be what Magnus has in store for
Yan and it's actually quite scare you to
face because D6 could be the next move I
wouldn't want to give the E6 Square to
the Black Knight but at the same time
that pawn is going D6 maybe D7 and it's
getting really close to the other side
yeah I admit the reason I initially
suggested it was because I hadn't made
on the brain with uh with Knight on F6
and maybe a G5 advance but it is it is
okay because you're trying to unpack
this and you're like okay there must be
something here what justifies a g-pawn
advance rather than G3 right and that's
like the only thing you can think about
is some sort of advanced idea of where
Magnus is playing for something very
long term here yeah I think that this is
a brilliant idea and I just say that you
and Robert together yeah are about as
strong as Magnus and stockfish together
really because I think that this is this
is maybe magnus's idea and his
preparation is this 98. somebody clip
and ship that please you should be on
camera right now because Danny's
blushing Danny's look I'm ready and
that's not a that's not a lighting
that's not a kid that's just pure
blushing and I was gonna compliment you
I know that's a shock I'm sure but yeah
you're you know you were thinking I knew
what you're thinking we've done enough
commentary together so from you know you
were thinking about Checkmate but your
head was in the right direction like
that side of the board is where white
needs to focus the energy because black
has the advantage on the queen side as
we keep discussing and I mean we can go
even further here because as we get to
Knight F6 check and then Knight to E8 it
makes you wonder like after D5 should
Black start rushing the a pawn up the
board because you have a rook behind
your past pawn and you'd like to keep
that going but this starts to get very
sharp people think that when Queens are
off the board it's not sharp it's not
tactical this position says otherwise
it's actually very sharp because one
inaccuracy can lead to a very
problematic position yep well we also
have to consider if white just starts
playing rushing the pawn down A4 D6 yeah
A3 D7 that pawn is immune on D7 because
again of the because of the Knight of
six Fork yep and so there's no just to
show everybody if you take with the
Knight you take with the Rook first and
you can't you can't do deal with the
four kind of F6 so why wins a piece so
black can play let's say Rook d8
but then you have to start considering
other tactics I think that this
works out for black because Knight F6
King G7 rookie eight black has Rook 3
takes D7 uh and and this would be most
likely a draw
yeah simplification Knight takes D7 and
I find it amazing when you look at how
crazy tactical the position is and how
accurate you are because the eval part
is just like yep that this is exactly
the best move
but but this is maybe there's something
here right that that Magnus is going for
sorry Robert go ahead one of the reasons
why when we were talking about D3 or
Rook B3 one of the reasons I actually
wanted to work on B3 is if you rush the
a-pump the board for black with a rook
on B3 you may get a rook B1 right upon
uh on the seventh rank is very dangerous
especially when a rook is on the
adjacent file because you can bring the
Rook to the last Rank and try to pry
away The Rook on A1 from the defense so
I don't know if it quite works out but
if I go A4 because I don't want to go
Rook takes B5 just to show that yeah one
more time for everyone it's Knight C7
well there's possibly Rook to A7 here
um but but maybe maybe there's D6 and
the on Pawn runs through uh because you
also can't play it's 97 first nice C7
Rook a seven black needs to save the
rook and then DC yeah okay yeah then and
D7 next and the pawn probably rushes
through okay yeah this is very
problematic so
um
if you go A4 we're having the same
Dynamic the same question all right both
pawns are running and the Knight on E8
is actually like not the difference just
to show Robert's point is well well um
maybe there's this oh no yeah a few
details funnily enough to work on D3 it
looks like it's controlling that pawn
better but actually it's less defendant
now because after Knight takes D7 Rook
takes D7 Rook takes E8 there's no Rook
hanging on D3
okay that's okay that's why the email
bar likes black we've solved that and
then if and if you don't have that eight
twos pretty scary
it's it looks like black plays A2 next
and we will see let's say King G2 A2
uh at this point white is forced to play
D7
to have Rook takes A2 after Rook B1 and
black plays Knight takes D7 actually
black ends up a pawn here because Rook
Knight D7 Rook D7 Rook E8 Rook takes a
two yeah one B5 in the end but it's a
draw but black isn't also Rook B1
instead of Rook takes E8
like after 97 Rook 67 here Rook B1 yeah
that's uh that's a problem that's the
main problem although you wonder if you
can actually take A2 and still have
decent jelly chances although you want
that many you know what I want I want I
want to prove that magnus's prep was so
deep the idea in the end is like a G5
and Y wins like there's no way to stop
me I mean I'm only half kidding you know
I know I knew exactly what you want you
want those types of games where you just
like in the end everyone goes
pray like the mind-blowing prep we have
a bunch of these moves so let's go oh
okay we'll catch up to the live position
there we go shake and bake
The Rook did go to D3 zero surprise here
Magnus made a slight face like on my D3
yeah ah a little slight face huh um but
it could mean nothing at all it's
possible that
um like I assume both were P3 and Rook
teacher objectively draw but maybe one
gives white slightly more practical
chances yeah create some problems for
black
um but yeah uh Magnus also he doesn't
look exactly thrilled that all this
happens
uh but maybe he has some idea in mind
like we were looking at with Knight of
six I was also thinking maybe Knight C7
and D5
is another way the Knight on C7 though
is very awkward but it can still go to
E8 eventually yeah same same uh square
of EA just a different route although
Knight C7 yeah okay let's analyze it all
right it could be very awkward because
after 97 Rook A7
and you play D5
like A4 happens and you can't get D6 in
so your pieces are in yeah now The Rook
on D3 actually is better yeah yeah so I
think I think it does make a difference
you have to go to F6 check
most likely yeah and white can just make
this draw right like 98 yeah obviously
and uh important point for everybody who
may not see it immediately is if we go
back negative six check just make it
again okay king h8 would be a very bad
move because the mating Nets that
Danny's been talking about it works here
you just line the second Rook up with
the H Pawn and you're taking on H7 and
it's just going to be pretty much a
fourth Checkmate Danny gets his wish
oh yeah
mate next move okay no uh obviously King
G7 is the move I have a small question
though
um
after
um 98
can black play King h8
after ooh I'm not sure that you
because maybe y just plays Rook 81
and the difference here everyone is at
Brook F7 the Knight is hanging
and so Rook a to E1 maybe and then
you're threatening Rook F7 yeah this it
looks a bit like black doesn't really
want to play like this it's a bit
unnatural
um because you really don't want a lot
of work of stuff and then your king gets
into your knight is is very bad on f8
your king gets into a mating net so the
best one might be king JB yeah although
in this line I started calculating in my
head A4 Rook F7 A3 Rook Edie
oh there's already I was known for H7 I
wanted the line you know where black
gets a queen and White's King is safe on
G2 that might also be winning it might I
think that might actually be winning
Rook H3 is some like kind of funny move
oh sacking the king to H3 and then the
queen comes to F1 yeah okay we're okay
sorry everybody we're back okay
all right that wouldn't work that was
fun
um by the way for those who may have
just tuned in the move Knight H4 on move
18. it was indeed a novelty it was the
move that had Bobby getting frisky over
here to my left and uh B takes A6 had
been played before and it was also
deeply analyzed as Fabi said by a lot of
people it was playing the correspondence
game so if you're just tuning in we had
a novelty by the world champion on move
18 but it was even more impressive how
quickly he followed it up with moves
like G4 and Knight G2 zero hesitation on
his plan obviously there's a lot about
this position that looks like it could
quickly Peter out but we're we're also
wait no no that's another analysis that
has not been played okay he's still
thinking after you still think about
night of Fate there's a lot about this
that could Peter out but we could also
see some very very deep prep at the end
of this game depending on where things
go I think we're suffering from the
Magnus effect Magnus effect magnusitis
we see by Magnus bias itis so it doesn't
seem as interesting because Jan has been
responding accurately yeah so that
doesn't mean it was a bad attempt from
Magnus it actually was quite a viable
attempt especially considering he was
not expecting the Petron that said we
tend to think Novelties from Magnus
Carlsen are automatically really good
and it wasn't that it was a bad move it
just doesn't lead anywhere because the
position is so solid the foundation for
black is there and in this position we
have two Rooks Five Pawns and a knight
per side and if we trade B6 and B5 and
D4 and A5 we're left with all these
pieces on the same side of the board
equal material there's nowhere to go so
I do think that Knight F6 check 98 does
give black some practical problems but
it's not like white is really able to
just rush everything through because
black has this a pawn The Rook on D3 is
extremely well placed the Rook on A8
covering the final Rank and the Knight
on E8 even though it's promoted to the
other side in all its Glory it actually
causes white some problems and lines
like we've seen when white tries to push
the pawn to D7 and sometimes are known
E8 could be a little bit loose so it's
an interesting position I still think
that there are chances but with accuracy
from Beyond which he has shown
throughout the match even when he's had
iffy positions he's been able to play
accurate moves and then even have an
advantage in game two with black here in
game four where how many moves in at
this point like 25 moves into this game
almost then Magnus played quickly played
preparation but Jan hasn't flinched a
bit
yeah I think the preparation question is
actually an interesting one I've given
it some thought personally because
sometimes
someone is very very well prepared as in
very deeply prepared but that doesn't
lead to a favorable outcome
because very often if you go for these
very theoretical lines they're the lines
most likely that your opponent is
checked too and Magnus has gone for a
line where
it's a bit less pressure on Jan as a
whole because he's reaching a position
pretty much on like let's say move 18 or
so even if he doesn't know Knight H4
um he knows the position is okay
it's a bit more simplified so his
options are more limited so he can he
can go through the options more easily
and
um
and he also has a massive reserve of
time so uh like in this case
Beyond with an hour and 24 minutes
um knowing that his position should be
equal even if he encounters some
practical tribe by Magnus
he should be able to figure it out
um and sometimes surprisingly you know
you you're playing over the over the
board you're completely out of prep but
you're able to find a good practical try
because you know you have that human
element which you can't really you can't
replicate analysis so you can
even inadvertently you can find a line
which is difficult for your opponent
because you're thinking naturally over
the board rather than going with the
computer which will just tell you the
objective evaluation
um so sometimes being very well prepared
is is not
even a great approach
um it's interesting to hear it that way
the
sorry my brain was just spinning there
and I started to go back to what Robert
said in terms of us suffering from
Magnus biasitis maybe he was bluffing a
little bit is there something to the
fact that Jan maybe played the Petrov it
actually did legit surprise him Magnus
remembered this line and went for it and
you know what what Hammer said when he
joined us when Robert called his bluff
on Sunday and said Magnus magnus's only
losses or the times he lost or maybe
almost lost actually came with with the
white pieces a couple times obviously he
lost the Sergey kariakin in 2016 with
white so you know I don't know I mean
I'm just trying to unpack this a little
bit and and make a guess as to why
Magnus may have gone for something where
he actually doesn't have as much as we
first thought he was shocked he was
shocked yeah I and I I think actually
kind of like the viewers were shocked
when we showed up but the world has
championships it's true very true but I
actually was a bit surprised by D4 I
moved five I I know that's early it's
it's the main move but as Fabiano was
talking about earlier there is this move
Knight C3 instead of D4 and there's a
huge debate a huge theoretical debate
about which gives more chances but
Knight C3 is one of these lines where
you can kind of I just have to trade on
C3 if we show this yeah all already the
pawn structure is different white gets a
semi-open d file but has these double
pawns and sometimes King's Castle on
opposite sides of the board and your the
plans are very rich and Magnus being
caught off guard probably didn't want to
go into these lines they want to do
something a little Tamer but I would
have liked to see Knight C3 on move four
or at least something that was a little
more
tactically challenging to get onto
palmistry because the way this game has
been going yes he played a really
interesting idea with Knight H4 but Jan
knew that the position was fine for him
and then now it's about as five minutes
using the human element John is an
exceptional chess player just because
he's done his preparation doesn't mean
he's not going to find the best moves
and he quite quickly found a very good
line for him and in the game it seems
like he has pretty much found a path
towards equality
Bobby you think if we get a Petrov again
we see Knight to C3 instead of D4 well I
think Magnus will also jump around
between different first moves um and you
made that prediction from the very
beginning so kudos to you on that you've
been right the whole time he did that to
Fabiano last time around so he knows
yeah knows a thing or two I think that's
his approach he's testing the waters a
bit the interesting thing about this
Knight C3 is that the last game I played
against Magnus before the match in 2018.
he played Knight C3
uh take take and he played a very rare
idea which is to put his Bishop on C4
usually people don't do this he does
very early on and I think that that sort
of stuff these ideas like it's not
putting the bishop C4 is not a great
idea it's not particularly threatening
for black but if uh the player would
block pieces doesn't know it and I
didn't know it it's very easy to get
into a slightly worse position and then
Magnus knows the plans well and I think
that's magnus's prep and that's Magnus
that is most dangerous when he has these
small lines like Bishop C4
his opponent doesn't know it super you
know in detail and he knows the ideas
very well and he confidently puts
pressure on you and I was very very
close to losing that game
um when Magnus goes for very direct
straight lines
uh it might not be the best approach for
him because he's a player who is
generally
stronger than than his contemporaries
um so he should be playing long games
where he wants to use his advantage to
advantages to the fullest rather than
going straight to a line where they're
just comparing calculation skills and
Magnus and Yan have
pretty much identical calculation skills
um yeah
so I don't know if this was the right
approach but again he's surprised by the
Petro up in the first game it's
difficult to react to a surprise on the
spot
um
you know he also probably thinks it's a
long match he can have time to test to
poke around a bit and then
um get some ideas for later games two
related questions for you so Jan has
played a lot of silly in his life
to some extent when you're playing a new
opening you have to have a feel for the
positions so what you're saying about
avoiding direct lines would force Jan to
have that feel to show that he
understands the positions the strategies
so I guess my question to you is someone
who has played against yawn many times
and I don't think you've played him when
he's played the Petro off against you
stylistically speaking do you think the
Petrov is a good opening freon
uh I think it was a good choice I mean
the petrol is an opening which is very
direct
um you avoid a lot of whites options
like the Italian you know you you just
for the scotch or the scotch LOL oh so
you you immediately get uh your opening
on the board yeah and and that really
limits what white can do you you only
have to worry about a few things which
makes your preparation uh a lot easier a
lot more simple
um so a well prepared prepared Petrov
can really shut down
down your opponent's uh E4 game like
entirely I think that that's what John
went for I think it was a good good
choice shutting down the E4 game what
Fabiano caruana has been doing for years
we're gonna take a a very very quick
break you won't miss a moment of the
action though so don't go anywhere of
course we'll continue to be tuned in to
the live position but we're gonna we're
gonna step back for just a few seconds
when we return it's more coverage of the
2021 feed a World Chess Championship by
the world Hess champion
[Music]
thank you
hi Jonathan Corbell again here in Dubai
at Expo 2020. Dubai has a rich chess
history first hosting an Olympiad in
1986. however never previously hosting a
World Chess Championship
which city has the record for hosting
the most World Chess championships
[Music]
thank you
is this so here's what we're saying
yes we will discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
foreign
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we got to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
's coverage of the 2021 v-day World
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
thank you
[Music]
this is this so here's what we're saying
yes
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
foreign
lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we got to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
foreign
lighting and audio
[Music]
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
I'm not such a beginner journalist to
ask you who the seconds are uh besides
you of course but let me ask you are the
other people that are helping him are
they all here on site or are some of
them around the world well of course you
have a strong team now and it's a great
contribution all the way helping to
Young and
connecting everything and the part of
our team is here and parties doing like
uh online job and so it's like always
happening during such great events
that's a very good answer you answered
it very diplomatically and finally what
about the early stages in the game today
they went right to the end game are you
happy with how he was prepared for
what's been happening on the board well
it's complex game so you will see what
happens so black has their own chances
so for example already we have a plus
pounds so if Magnus will not take care
about that in some pound end game with
him help us
there we are the long time second of
John Napoli Grand Master of Vladimir
putkin thanks for your time thank you
good stuff there from Dubai we'll
continue to be checking with Mike
throughout the entire event remind you
that you just saw our trivia question at
the break brought to you by Jonathan
corbla you can play along by quote
tweeting from the officialchess.com
account your answer we didn't know the
answer what city had the most World
Championships we quickly guessed maybe
London maybe Moscow so we don't know one
of those but interesting stuff so hope
you play along for a chance to win a
one-year Diamond membership if you're
the first one to quote tweet and get it
correct let's also remind you that uh we
we vote and and have a lot of fun at the
start of every show if you're not voting
at chess.com if you're not voting in
chat you're missing it show up a little
bit earlier today we had 58 percent in
chat both that Magnus was going to win
30 a draw and oberonchess.com we had 45
percent people voting and for Magnus to
win at 45 voting for a draw interesting
deadlock there so all right we got some
moves here boys let's look in I think
that vote makes sense though by the way
yeah yeah
because on slash events you got pretty
serious chess crowd in there on Twitch
you got maybe some more Magnus fans Rudy
from on his birthday so
um you know Magnus of course would love
to win on his birthday and we're getting
the variation we were talking about with
Knight F6 and the Knight E8 check I
think we have um I'm going to do a new
poll oh
100 100
draw and you think it's happened right
now Knight f698 repetition I don't think
it's gonna happen now I mean he he
always has his repetition in his pocket
um
but yeah I think it's still pretty much
100 at this point
well when we left you at the break
everyone we had the position with Knight
f8 on the board and while we were gone
for a few minutes and hopefully you
enjoyed the uh the question not a lot
happened it was exactly the line we had
been predicting so if you've been here
with us you know that Fabiano is uh is
playing the the role of the Prophet here
and and uh
let's hope he's wrong this time though I
will say if there's a decisive result
I'll be thrilled because
um we all want to see action
and
um
I think we're all hoping for for a lot
of action today but young young really
played it very accurately so far
um and
that's my my general feeling I mean also
like he he has so much time that he
doesn't
I don't think that he's going to feel
Under Pressure which is when mistakes
start to occur is when when you know
players get nervous and everyone gets
nervous from
from a beginner to to Magnus Carlson uh
but when you know your position is good
and you have a ton of time uh these guys
are not going to be getting too nervous
yeah and Magnus spent quite a deal of
time making his decision to go Knight F6
check 98 so you sound like Jan should be
concerned that he's getting pressured on
the board the Magnus is playing quickly
and confidently Magnus is making faces
he's not thrilled to be in the position
that he's in he would love to score his
first victory in the world champion
classical chess since 2016.
but as I said yesterday MasterCard buys
you a lot of things doesn't buy you a
victory no it cannot do that how how
long did it take for you to get your
first win in the world has Championship
I think I was born when you were bored
with the dub yeah I was man and people
don't know this but both of my parents
names start with the letter c so I was
born you were born someone born in the
Darkness
somewhere some
you went Batman Bane and I didn't I
wasn't ready to respond that's a rare a
rare dub for you in the pop culture game
but seriously uh I think that merch is
looking good I hope that everyone heads
over and gets themselves
the world has championship gear
[Music]
um
all right
I think I think for magnus's birthday we
might send him a little bit of world has
Championship Swag by the way yeah yeah I
think we will okay well he's sitting
here he's trying to figure it out and I
guess what he's doing is as Fabiana said
he can make the draw whenever he wants
yeah I'd have six check 98 check the
king will go up to G7 back to G8 so he
has that drawn his pocket and this is a
smart thing to do so for everybody who's
watching who may consider playing in
tournament chess you don't want to rush
a draw when you have one because you can
do it at any moment even if you have
five seconds left on your clock well
maybe not in this game because there's
no increment until they read the third
time Patrol so five seconds a little bit
too generous for the opponent but still
the point remains that Magnus can think
for the next hour trying to find is D5
actually more promising for me or does
that help Yan to some extent and then
maybe yawn say I'm not going to make a
draw I'm going to try to beat you with
the a pawn running up the board so if
Magnus deems it unnecessary or
potentially risky he can just make this
draw now if he says why not play on I'm
not in any trouble I can make this draw
at any moment let's see if Jan responds
accurately the problem is Jan's moves A4
A3 or kind of obvious Bobby I see you're
feeling I can tell when you're when you
got that pose right you're feeling as
fresh as Bobby wait Bobby as fresh as
Fabi yeah that's that's what AF now
means man you're feeling foggy AF let's
go
show us the line you're thinking about
in your head we're gonna bring up the
analysis board I think some I think
there's either draw or D5 okay because
black is threatening Rook takes D4 D5
um what I was actually thinking about
was which of the Nolan Batman films are
the best ones definitely The Dark Knight
definitely the dark I I might have to
Batman Begins was pretty good
it actually is low-key under race
what Liam Neeson Loki okay I'm with you
on that five yeah no I think it's I'll
give you an email please Christopher
Nolan Batman movies are overrated hot
take uh besides the third one compared
to I have to you're like Danny DeVito as
the Penguins all right let's continue
first of all Michelle Pfeiffer was
low-key underrated as a bad guy in that
movie for sure yeah
so the point everyone if you just tuned
in Rook takes D5 fails to a fork of
magnus's choosing we we actually looked
at a very forcing line already earlier
which was A4 D6 A3 and the point is that
D7 actually can be met by Knight takes
not because of Rook takes D7 actually no
because of Rook takes C7 yeah yeah uh
you can't meet it with Knight takes but
D7 instead will be met by Rook d8 yeah
and and this will lead to a massive
simplification because the A3 and D7
pawns are both going to get traded off
and the B pawns as well and then we're
we're in a three versus three yep so so
but I'm also wondering after D5 if black
plays Rook to C8
um I here maybe Knight D6 actually this
allows Knight to D6 and
um white gets that episode Okay so
but yeah it's not I think too difficult
to calculate A4 because it's a very
straightforward line wide pushes black
pushes
um we might see this or the thing is
like Magnus can think for an hour as
Robert mentioned that always have that
safety node of a draw yeah but you also
Tire yourself out by by that and yeah uh
I don't know if you want to expend all
that energy when you know that you're
probably not going to find anything or
maybe his birthday dinner reservation
yeah maybe he's got birthday dinner well
on a serious note though how much
goes into your head psychologically I
know that the whole world was talking
about the draws you guys had in 2018
right did you guys manage to keep
yourselves in a bubble in regards to
like hey right forget the haters like
we're focused on the highest quality
chess you guys also know in your world
just how close some of those games were
to being decisive so you don't really
care so that's one version or or does it
weigh on you like do you do you look at
this with a little bit of frustration if
you're Magnus and go like you know
schmarn it foiled again right it's you
know here I have to go dealing with the
questions again of another draw
yeah I think you learn at some point to
tune out what people are saying okay
um mainly because
well whatever you do you're not going to
make everyone happy yep and uh
and you certainly don't want to lose
yeah you mainly don't want to lose the
main thing is to win the match I mean
people will say a lot during the match
but it doesn't really matter what they
say because it's all decided on the end
result and if you win nobody can say
anything
uh so yeah also like in terms of being
in the bubble I what I did was I just
didn't have my phone for the match uh so
I tried to stay completely away from
social media uh from any exposure
I hadn't I hadn't had the pleasure of
playing back then
but yeah I I tried to stay completely
isolated from from the outside world
um and anyway during the match it was
like
chess when I wasn't sleeping it was just
chess there was nothing it was either uh
preparation for the game or the game so
I don't know if that's the approach of
the players they might take some time to
play sports and do some
um do some things to take their mind off
chess and and de-stress for a bit
uh but mostly I think that for them it's
also going to be
you know 99 chess and uh that's all you
could focus on during the world
championship match when we think of
doing chess preparation we often think
of opening Theory and working with your
seconds how much did you
do puzzles and things like that during
the match like to keep yourself
calculations right so rather than just
the opening stage just keeping yourself
sharp in the event of a crazy tactical
position or trying to find the precise
way through an end game during the match
um not at all like that's mostly
training
you want to make sure you're in shape
before the game start once the game
start you're already in calculation mode
and and you quickly get into shape if
you're not but the problem is that those
first few games if you're not in shape
those can really mess you up so so yeah
during the match I I don't think that
you want to because you know calculation
even if it's um
uh just not in in a game and even if it
doesn't have all the tension of and and
pressure of a game it still takes energy
and you don't want to be expending
energy when you're already going to be
losing plenty of that just from the
match itself
excellent insights from Fabiano core one
let's remind you we also have Robert
Hess over here if you're just tuning in
this will be the crew that's taking you
all the way through goodbye we had a
holiday weekend for those uh in the
United States over the last few days so
some of you may actually be tuning into
your first World Chess Championship game
of 2021 lucky for you it's also the
first day of the world has championship
and uh we hope that you're you stick
with us throughout and this was a Petrov
we had a lot of very interesting opening
insights from Fabiano and oh okay so
we're not we're not getting the the
repetition just yet we do have D5 on the
board from Magnus and we see him write
it down and then lean back in his chair
and but not getting up nearly as much as
yon we will say that he's not getting up
from the board is that just a oh
well just prove Dan wrong you know
well I think they yawn even when he gets
up he's still thinking about the
position yeah is that I was just about
to say is that more of like just a
personality thing a lot of players there
are a lot of players who almost are
never at the board when it's not their
turn yeah
um for those who've never played over
the board chess it is actually a thing
that uh that some players develop the
habit of yeah it's very much a
preference I don't even think we can say
which is a better approach
um it looks it sounds like you know you
should always be at the board
concentrating and saving your time
thinking on your opponent's move but it
also helps sometimes to just not look at
the board to rest your eyes you know
that that's important too
um I think the value should also be
placed on
um thinking about Chess and tournaments
also as long Affairs and energy is an
important factor of them
um
like you don't want to expend all your
energy
um constantly calculating and and never
getting giving your brain some rest yeah
that makes sense so yeah yep
well as we just saw it is move 27 for
those of you asking in chat how far we
are from time control 13 moves away at
move 40 time is added back as you saw
and as we now see Yawn is back at the
board
um every time he comes back he's wearing
a little less clothing
keep it on Jan
well he uh he's back he's ready I'm
guessing he'll make his move relatively
quickly with this A4 the only downside
of playing move A4 is that pawns and
especially past pawns like to be
protected by other pawns so if he feels
like his Pawn may get stranded be a bit
too too far and white can just try to
Corral it that would be one thing but
we're looking at very forcing variations
it's not like he needs to calculate too
much because A4 threads A3 well
eventually want to play A2 so I think
white in order to avoid having that pass
Pawn for black run down the board
we need to do exactly what we've been
looking at with D7 or the Knight f698
draw that's always available
it is interesting when you have a
repetition in hand in regards to the
time control discussion because even
more even more likely that both player
both players make move 40 with ease
as as sometimes that that little game of
tickle will be thrown in just uh okay
let's try something here so after A2
okay so zoom out oh so um
yeah yeah
we want to talk about why A2 isn't as
good yeah this Knight of six check
and then rookie eight right and rookie
eight yeah okay
okay so so yeah after Rook theater I
don't see any ideas
so rook d8 and okay let's let's play
Knight F6 check again and
and rookie eight
um Rook three takes D7 it's a four scene
line Knight takes D7 group takes E8
Knight takes B6
what's a rook to B8 although at this
point many moves are a draw Knight C4
tag group takes A3 and we have three
against three
um like it's slightly better like
however the F4 uh Outpost well it's
slightly overextended yeah but let's go
over here not enough for it to be
anything besides the draw
yep
interesting indeed and
you know we saw how quickly Magnus was
playing at the start of the game the
body language was uh
expressing confidence and Poise but as
Robert Robert said in hindsight we might
have just seen a little bit of a bluff
from Magnus it's just good preparation
by John the Palmer she's here yeah and
we've been talking game after game how
in the opening stage this has been a
storyline Magnus Carlson has won the
battle his preparation has been quite
good he has not always found the best
follow-up no human chess player is
perfect but his starts of the games have
been great this game he was surprised on
move two and when you're shocked that
early
that's tough because if you're shocked
I'll move 10 you've already maybe traded
some pieces there's some maneuvering
that you can do that just is like all
right we're already at a point that some
things have happened that make the
position
clarified in some manner but when it's
moved to
it's kind of ambiguous like what does my
opponent want from me when it's moved 10
you're already at a point where it's
like okay I already see what's happening
now my opponent just made the third most
popular move instead of the main line
let's move two you're like okay I could
go through
12 different options that are
equivalently good but which one does Jan
want to see and which does he not and at
that point you might as well you're
guessing yeah put a blindfold on and
just point your finger and hope that you
found the one that John didn't prepare
as deeply or that the one he doesn't
feel as comfortable in because you're
surprised on the second move of the game
yep
makes sense makes a lot of sense
um
I don't know if it makes a lot of sense
that Jan is thinking so deeply here but
this might just be one of those double
checking how forced the variations are
ahead making sure that he feels
confident he's not being
not being tricked I I think it makes
sense for him to think because he has
over an hour yep he um this is probably
going to be the last decision he will
have to make in this game
uh if he makes a good one because this
this is really I mean A4 is going down a
very forcing line so he can basically
calculate it to the end
um and if he decides that for some
reason there's something after A4 he
doesn't like he can try another move
like Rook to D4 or it's actually not
clear what else black can can really do
besides A4 because Rook to C8 isn't
working out very well
um and other moves don't actually like
you can't attack this deep on so it's
going down the board whether you like it
or not so you basically should respond
in turn if white were able to get
another move here and play Rook A4 maybe
he would actually
um like let's say black plays I don't
know Rook to D2
something silly and why it plays Rook to
A4 this starts to look like also Rook F4
is coming starts to look a bit uh it's
suspicious for black
and the lack of the lack of ability to
push the a pawn is obviously kind of
game changing there so another reason
why Rook D2 doesn't make a lot of sense
it seems like if you were going to do
anything but push the pawn you would
have put the Rook on the B file to go
after go after B3 right sorry B5 so
other idea I can think of for black is
to play G5
get the night active in another way but
you don't really want to do this it
looks very risky it looks a lot less
direct and forcing than the media A4 yep
um and you might also get started to get
hit with Knight F6 Knight H5 stuff like
um white white has a lot of you know
um
why it's only gets a lot of options A4
is officially on the board
we are yeah
having a hard time
anticipating moves that uh that won't
lead to the forcing lines that
that you said so
a good time to remind Chad that this is
uh maybe maybe the part of the day where
you can ask questions to Fabiano
we've been we've been choosing at least
one every day that was a great question
and uh Fabiano given even better answers
so
Let's uh
let's do that right now maybe for the
next 10 minutes or so our staff and mods
will pay super close attention give us a
question for Fabiano and remind you if
you didn't if you didn't get the memo we
are going to be debuting our classroom
feature a new feature coming from
chess.com connecting coaches and
students around the world uh real-time
video integration directly in the
browser it's going to be awesome and
we're super excited to Premiere it with
a private group lesson with Fabiano
caruana I get to be there too so there's
actually 11 super excited fans uh
sitting with Fabiano as as he gives us a
one hour lesson on December 13th which
could be the last rest day I believe if
there's no tie breaks so make sure that
you you play along all you got to do is
solve at least one video Lesson from
Fabiano's new video series on chess.com
which is amazing you should be you
should be doing it anyway because it was
amazing content from Fabiano even Robert
watched the lesson uh despite the fact
that I was in those videos against his
will
um so you should definitely watch the
watch the video series and then you just
take a screenshot and tweet or insta as
proof to be automatically registered to
win
regardless of what happens at the end of
day we have a ton of guests as always
but our first guess is how we Fawn four
times women's world champion uh she'll
be joining us very very soon so we're
going to get her insights and thoughts
hoey Fawn is uh just on the other side
of our next break which we're going to
take we're going to take right now we
think the players are going to be
thinking for a minute so a good time for
us to quickly reset ourselves let ifon
join the studio chess.com's coverage of
the 2021 Peter World Chess Championship
is brought to you by coinbase and it
returns in just a moment ah come on hey
come on check it out check it out hey
you know spitting magma just to draw you
in like a magnet my gameplay magnificent
like Magnus when they come to Rhymes
close my eyes and let go I keep it
Dynamic kinda like I was nefo got the
kind of Rhymes y'all compete for years
don't change the dial y'all keep it here
and we about to take it Beyond three day
Chess Championship on chess.com
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody as chess.com's
coverage of the 2021 v-day World Chess
Championship continues we are joined yet
again by a world chess champion ho efon
four-time women's world champion is
calling in Daley bringing us her
thoughts uh Yvonne I'm just gonna you
know kind of spoiler alert I think your
thoughts are going to be centered around
the prediction of a draw but maybe not
take it away
uh well actually before drawing out uh
let's say before drawing the commentary
team I thought that there might be
already a drawer but some yeah just
don't move 27 that Magma's play the move
B5 and then I mean at the list of the
game continues but most likely yes the
prediction will still be a drawer as the
position looks quite trollish be fun we
were pretty surprised that John de
palmisi played the second move Knight F6
and got into the Petrov you have World
Championship experience yourself have
you ever been shocked that early by your
opponent let's bring up the analysis
board as we do that so we Fawn can give
us her thoughts on the uh on the picture
go ahead Yvonne
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because I was firstly trying to
[Music]
I love deep analysis so therefore a
patch of this opening actually became
way more com popular in the last uh
almost a decade interesting and now by
the way we've we've seen G5 on the board
from Carlson so at the very least this
game will continue and I'm I'm getting
excited because this was this was the
idea I hoped uh we might see not because
white is immediately getting black in a
mating net but just because it justifies
a little bit of this unique uh part of
the novelty that came with move 18
Knight H4 You could argue was the
follow-up 19 G4 the whole idea uh
perhaps to justify a long term long-term
bind whether it ever becomes a mating
that or not so with G5 on the board are
you thinking that Magnus might be
pushing this for for a little bit longer
than we thought
yeah I guess so definitely I mean
there's still something to play with uh
firstly as you say this nylon F6 a very
strong square and also the black Lionel
fa is kind of inactive however black has
a very good counter play with this a
passport right that could
more or less let's say restrict the
local ao1 therefore one may not have
enough uh forces to coordinate together
and attack Black's key and they point
out I guess one of the most interesting
manure in the game so far this Knight H4
G4 and 9. and we may indeed have lost
ephon there so we're gonna
we're gonna continue here which is
having a little bit of connection issues
today so let's let's let's keep
analyzing the the live position here if
we can Robert G5
G5 on the board and she was saying yeah
there is maybe some long-term chances
here your thoughts there certainly are
for example a black president of H6
trying to remove the defender of the
Knight on F6 that would be a mistake you
see the evaluation bar going up uh first
98 check right we were talking about how
the king wants to stay attached to this
Pawn F7 and if you're King G8 then you
drop this Pawn on H6 and that starts
getting very problematic because if you
just go back to that position real
quickly Knight F6 check forces the king
to the corner which is exactly what you
didn't want so H6 or or did I want it I
don't think so uh well you want it for
white that's for sure but the thing
about this position is that black in
many ways shouldn't do anything because
if you do something trying to you know
undermine the nice defense that's how
you lose this game right but if you keep
pushing the a pawn down you have a rook
behind a pass Pawn you go A3 you go away
two it's not like G5 threatened anything
you just defended the Knight and here
we're seeing a position where you do
need to be careful because if you push
all the way down here there could be a
D7 a rookie a to d8 type of thing and
The Rook takes A2 will be in play at
some point but we heavy fun back hello
efon thank you for rejoining us it's
okay I'm sorry yes
I feel like talking 90
friends subtly I realized some the zoom
just like kind of disconnected yeah but
I feel like you're announcing a very
interesting position actually so let's
just continue okay because we were just
looking at A3 D6 again the pawn can't be
taken because of a fork uh but a A2
would go too far because of similar
lines we looked at with Fabi with D7
suddenly Rook E8 is a threat so that
makes me wonder if Bobby's or I think it
maybe was Robert's suggestion the key is
you leave the pawn on A3 where it's now
protected by a new rook and actually
change this works purpose Robert to
coming over to d8 your thoughts on that
idea epon
yeah that's also like a reasonable try
because
uh let's say this at this point A3 is
already a very let's say uh strong
enough to uh for zerochon A1 but the
point is we play the other account d8
what's next because we still can not
take back to this exponent uh so maybe
next month is night e for blacks or what
I mean it depends on what's the plan
yeah for black because it's three five
nine F6 it could just stay here forever
and why it's next plan probably
one day to bring the king join the game
or King G2 Roxy one sample moment and
hope for cc7
when there's no check when the queen
well
and I'll add that H6 becomes
increasingly likely if black is able to
coordinate in this manner because we're
talking about uh before A3 because if we
go back right it's an H6 immediately was
not good because 98 check and that would
get the H6 Pawn but 98 check the king
doesn't have to move right it's not
forced to move you can sacrifice your
Rook on E8 for that Knight so in some
positions maybe there's a time where you
can even bail out if you start getting
in trouble for black no there's probably
something very
specific that allows black to not have
to worry but as soon as you have this
configuration Pawn G5 Knight F6 you're
very worried about checkmates and you've
definitely had that in the brain for a
long while
yeah you fun if we if we take a big step
back and ask you the the questions we do
daily about what it feels like in this
moment
you're you're the world champion and you
haven't won a classical chess game in a
really long time yet the advantage here
is is is going to be very small at best
right you know you're trying to squeeze
water out of a stone a little bit is
there a psychological trap there at all
to to push a little too hard and did you
ever feel the pressure of a result out
with outside circumstances that had
nothing to do with what was on the board
uh well actually yes the idea that very
often and I could still remember Club of
my let's say uh unsuccessful experience
on that so that I got a better position
which is clearly better but maybe
nothing more than a tiny initiative and
I keep going and keep going on and
sometimes I was lucky that I could
manage to survive from a worse position
that due to the reason I pushed too much
but sometimes you might just uh let's
let's say mess it up but according to my
own experience I felt that I uh did it
you know more modest way when when I was
employing the world championship match
that means I didn't try to play too much
when I see that there are not so many
things that happening on the board
and I I guess here our situation about
this game Magnus is way more stronger
and more experienced uh you know in
compared to my case right so I guess
that shouldn't be a concern for him for
him or maybe foreign as well because
they definitely have the ability to keep
it within their control and also here we
see that why to be honest do not have
much risks so I think it's very happy to
play such a position because the term
situation is kind of even right so now I
really need uh in this particular game
and why it has more comfortable piece it
could decide let's say some moments just
to clarify the position so I see no
reason that
um you know any side might go uh let's
say exactly right and that's very
different from game two right you find
where in game two Magnus was really just
out of the opening stage but with an
advantage but if you go wrong in that
type of position as he did he was in big
trouble here it's hard to see him going
wrong without a tremendous blunder
because he has these 98 Knight F6 check
to make a draw his Pawn on D5 is a pass
Pawn that can go up to D6 and so it does
seem like it's difficult
how magnets can really go wrong but it's
the thing is if you keep going and that
hate Pawn runs up the board that is a
way you potentially get in trouble but
I'm with ephon that it seems like Magnus
has minimal risk
if on when you last joined us on Sunday
we talked about the break day giving
Magnus maybe a little bit of an
advantage because his team would have
more time with white but but you made
the comment that at the same time John's
team has more time with black and maybe
it was debatable which uh you know which
was more valuable were you kind of
proven right here with uh with John
Young's Petrov seemed to have surprised
Magnus and what what do you see about
the rest of the match in terms of what
color would you want to have going into
the rest day for your team would you
rather have white or would you rather
have black going into the rest day
well to me no difference at all okay I
mean yeah but basically because we will
at least play two games right so you
need to prepare both not only let's say
the game that come in the next day but
also uh the day after right because we
will have less time to uh prepare
between the games if there is no rest
day so to be honest it's it's really
very similar but actually I say that
it's very interesting that Carlson tried
the first game with let's say uh D4 this
catalog and the second wide game with E4
so I don't know that if he's going to
balance this opening strategy or maybe
at first they just decided to test the
opponent and see which opening uh let's
say variation he might uh hope for more
uh let's say in the opening and then he
will decide to go for that with that
probably sounds like another interesting
strategy
Fabiano has predicted that Magnus will
continue to poke in prod to different
things with white to to try to find a
hole in your world championship matches
was that how did you generally take the
strategy in the first stage to be to be
stubborn if you felt like there was one
approach that was going to expose
weaknesses or did you as a person who
was often the stronger player defending
your title did you also take the
strategy of kind of mixing it around a
little bit to try to probe for
weaknesses
uh well to me probably uh wasn't that
really hard working so it would be very
hard that if I try to play different
albums and try to test versus
you won four world champions myself
uh well this side design almost depends
right decide on whom it would like to
compare with and like what degree what
exactly you're talking about hard
working right
so that was not like the best or at the
maximum but yeah so therefore I felt
that for me
I was like just focus on let's say one
big Direction I mean of course there
might be some small change so you try
this and there are little things uh but
also if let's say it's really too hard
to find anything in this big Direction
it's also possible to switch but not
like here for example uh first match uh
first game Castle and next game Pedro so
uh well that's a huge right that's a
huge thing but also it depends on the
knowledge the current Place everything
but for me I wasn't that Universal uh
let's say talking about opening wise
that's actually really interestingly fun
because in the 2018 match against
Fabiano Magnus chose a different first
move he would go D4 and then C4 then E4
so he would mix and match and his
Universal style is something that has
helped him become the highest rated
player in chess history but I guess in a
match perspective you find you were
saying how you stuck to a specific
opening maybe you switched A variation
within that opening umbrella I mean for
if you're a magnus's coach if you're in
his corner and as someone who's watched
the games very closely in all of his
last World Championships I mean would
you recommend that maybe he keeps going
in one specific opening a couple more
times or do you like his mix and match
strategy of playing D4 than E4 and then
C4 because it does make him a bit
unpredictable on any given day
well I think it's definitely a good try
I'm not sure if that's the best but it's
definitely a worse to try to why because
uh again you know at their level already
they know almost everything in the
opening so if you keep only let's say
one specific open knee first game you
get nothing second time you made a small
Improvement and maybe your opponent has
been 10 minutes and you know or even in
during the homework they already solve
the problem then another boring game so
you simply kind of just like waste a
couple of games in the match right so
it's making sense that you try
differences and also psychologically it
might make your opponent a little bit
unpleasant because you come to the board
to the board and you don't know what to
expect or let's say you are ready for
anything so that's the other thing right
so that could also makes your opponent
of feeling a bit uncertain this
uncertain is actually a very good thing
of Mercury he's seen during the match so
I thought that's a good strategy if
yourself who tried to try the for
instance can hold the situation that's
the most important is that you have this
ability then that's a good thing well
said yep and
not exactly sure uh
magnus's team expected the the Petrov in
this game and maybe that's
maybe that's going to mean no more E4 so
even though we're talking about his
strategy to bounce around
what do we think if if he sees the
Petrov as something that John has
revealed that he prepared are we less
likely to see E4 again it could be a
one-off thing from Jan though just like
Magnus is mixing and matching perhaps
Jan is saying I'm showing you the Petrov
you're going to come back with E4 and
then I'll play the Sicilian because we
know Jan has played so many times he
also can go into a Spanish Berlin so we
don't actually know what Yan is
preparing either he is fresh to the
World Championship it's his first time
in it and unlike the caruana Carlson
match where they were just testing each
other at least when 500 was white he
kept going into those Sicilians of those
Ross limos we don't yet know if Yan will
do the same thing and you know it
definitely remains to be seen because
when Jan has been white he plays E4 but
then he played A4 rather than H3 so he's
decided to switch it up relatively early
epon is it is it a little
is it a little more scary to play the
same thing as black though I mean what
is the what is the thought on that is it
do you get worried about playing the
same thing as black because because
maybe it's more likely to White compress
with an engine advantage or is it the
opposite do you feel like if you find a
solid defense you should you should keep
it if you're young
uh in the match in this match right
yeah in this match
yeah okay yeah so in this case I thought
that it depends on the opening right so
for example if patch off against E4 I
don't think there are a lot of things to
worry about if you did a variative
analysis well let's say for example
um if that's Sicilian for example if
that's not of I guess it might a bit
tricky compared to Pedro okay
well I guess we're all making our best
guess here Yvonne I think I think we're
gonna we're gonna let you let you head
out and remind everybody that you'll be
joining us daily right around the same
time and uh maybe at some point by the
time you join it'll be harder for you to
predict the result but we keep asking
you to predict the result I'll do so
again your thoughts on where this game
is going to end
wow so far it's not a tough job for me
right as I join at this moment
so again the drawer will be my
prediction but not just to somebody with
worry that if I'll keep this prediction
for the rest of the match like every day
probably be right more than you were
wrong for sure if you predicted the draw
but yes at some point I believe you're
gonna join and we're gonna have a little
more fire on the board a little more
unclear but right now you're beating me
and Bobby and Hess and your predictions
so good job on that and uh we will uh
we'll see you once again on the other
side of uh of tomorrow's opening stage
all right and uh as we say good goodbye
to ephon we see that Magnus is uh is
still thinking at the board here in our
lovely in studio Cam and we're gonna
we're gonna take a very very quick break
when we return of course Fabiano Carr
wanted will be back we'll continue to
dive into all the action in the game in
game four of the 2021 feet a World Chess
Championship
today chess.com joins you from old Dubai
long before there was the Burj Khalifa
or any of those Mega structures this is
where the action was and in fact in 1986
the chess Olympiad was played here thus
the statue in the background
commemorates that we have a camel with a
rook on top I'm not sure if that species
is actually native to the desert now a
little language lesson in Arabic Rook is
I can also tell you that back in 86 the
Soviet Union took gold England got
silver USA took bronze now will Russia
come out back on top at the end of these
three weeks or will Norway be back in
first place stay tuned for more coverage
as we find out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
.com is proud to release game review a
simple streamlined tool to help you
learn from your games immediately see
your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations
play a game start review and try it
today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
because I think in modern chairs you got
to be
very Universal player if you want to be
successful and you can't rely on the
information alone
so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example a player a royal Chamberlain
would be the best intuition ever is we
have a child but
I guess he also had you know
he he had to calculate a lot yeah and
for example today if you you could try
to to stick to his playing his style
sometimes it will be very costly to to
your performance I think yeah the
intuition is always good but
I mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move
because of your calculation or
evaluation you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar but humidity sounds you you you
get a big one and okay probably here the
intuition comes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hard rock music or something yeah so to
to feel the energy and feel the power
but I mean in general it's
I mean it really depends on the mood and
the mood can be different from from one
day to another
it's not some kind of a ritual I'm
trying
[Music]
we're back with the 2021 v-day World
Chess Championship day one of the world
Hess Championship if you haven't picked
up your your gear yet it's flying off
the shelves not sure if Bobby is even
going to get one after his
General attitude about it
um you don't have any any shirts for me
well again dude you you know you didn't
want one well you know we'll let
everybody see we caught it on video but
I might be able to get you one we'll see
all right that looks good on you though
we'll take it um welcome back everybody
we hope you're having a good time let's
remind you that on our rest days we have
the speed Chess Championship might as
well rename the rest day to speed Chess
Championship day boy did we have a
thriller yesterday seriously
congratulations on that match Fabiano
coming back and beating Maxine Bache the
grav Rapport versus Sauron report versus
nihal on Thursday should also be a
thriller talk about two super Dynamic
aggressive players right we are going to
have decisive chess if you need some
wins on a chessboard tune in on the rest
day to the speed Chess Championship and
if you happen to be tuning in to the
chess Channel no matter where you are
hit subscribe or follow especially if
it's your first time all right this is
not Magnus Carlson's first time but
he's hoping to get his first win in a
very long time Fabiano
yeah I think it's gotten a bit more
interesting Magnus has really taken his
time here
um
but he he basically showed that he wants
to continue his game by not pushing his
deep on forward because that would have
led to the force line that we mentioned
here he keeps his Knight entrenched on
F6 basically his entire point is your
night on f8 is dominated the question is
can white make progress here because if
white were to play immediately D6 okay
we'll look at it
again the pawn is immune as we saw in in
other lines very similar lines Rook
takes c698 wins The Rook so black can't
do that and if A2 I think now D7 is
super strong
I think this would be very bad for black
the difference is after Rook d8 if black
plays the same line that we saw in the
other position Rook takes A2
instead of Rook to E8 oh okay Rook takes
A2 now Knight takes D7
Rook 2 to A7 oh wow Rook t7 oh Knight
takes up six Rook takes F7 all the pawns
collapse white wins the game so this is
the difference
um I believe
it's a huge difference right there but
after D6 I don't see a way for white to
continue after Knight to E6
because
oops sorry that pawn on G5
is falling off
yeah and once that black knight gets out
that that was White's huge Advantage not
objective evaluation but we compare
piece to piece right the Knight on F6
was so much stronger than Knight f8
because with the pawn D5 the 9fa can't
move and we already discussed why H6 is
not an idea that black can get away with
because of 98 check and then you're
going to lose a pawn so D6 immediately
allows that Knight to come out into the
position and I like Fabiano's point that
if you go A2 that seems like such a
natural move you're going one step
closer to promotion but it actually puts
your Pawn on a potentially vulnerable
Square because your Rook on D3 is a
second defender of the Pawn on A3 so as
soon as you go Pawn A2 your Rook on A8
right could be a bit overloaded and
because the Knight is defended on F6
they're all these checkmating patterns
with you want to essentially pick up
that rook and put it on G8 right that's
what you would do in this position if
you could jump that Rook to G8 it would
be Checkmate so
either Rook whichever one it is for
those of us that are visual Learners yes
and
um I was gonna say I thought you were
going to say if you pick up the rook in
front of the seventh rank which is also
very effective anything I would also win
yeah
anything is better than where the Rook
currently stands on A1 but that's
precisely the problem right without
without an idea like that
well there is your idea just just to
point out you mentioned this crazy idea
in a previous line Rook to C1 here A2
Rook one to C7 let me just look at that
on the board okay so if Magnus were to
play Rook C1 here okay which he will not
do
but after A2 Rook one to C7 you
mentioned this idea yes allow the queen
and then King G2 because root takes F7
is made if white were given the move
unfortunately Queen takes F6
eliminates that uh
yeah that mating Knight
black gets out giving up a queen is
worth it if it weren't for that I
actually don't know
uh how else black easily stops is made
maybe there's also Knight D7 and Rook to
f8 uh that I might also uh be a cold
shower but Queen takes F6 is easy enough
Rook H3 again is also some kind of cool
possibility yeah also a weird move to
try to to try to tempt the king up and
open up the F1 Square for the queen but
okay these are this is a fantasy here
um so I'm actually wondering about
instead of Rook C1 to move H4
because black is not easily like white
can't do very much at the moment but
neither can black so easily so maybe it
just makes sense to support that pawn on
G5 because in some lines that pawn could
be come hanging and you that's the only
Advantage white has here is the Pawn on
G5 and 9 on F6 this this
um bind that white has both the limiting
906 potentially also with uh mating nuts
so H4 has a generally useful move asking
black what do you do in return makes
sense to me and if black continues to
push A2 every time we see that pawn
touch down on a square where it's not
protected by both Rooks as Robert said
that's where you can maybe get some
tactical problems starting with maybe
something like D6 I think specifically
A2 has a problem a very unique problem
here which is Rook to E2 a surprising oh
wow you just come all the way back and
this Knight is perfect where it stands
if you get rid of that a pawn wide wins
it's that simple yeah so black has to
play Rook D to A3 to support that pawn
and that white can maybe play yeah maybe
Rook D2 maybe just D6 immediately then
D7 and then you you sack on A2 because
that d-pawn will uh will promote if
black ever leaves the eight
um the eighth rank with the Rook
so maybe this is dangerous for luck
fascinating because H4
wallet
you know is it isn't the most exciting
move it's actually a really great again
high quality kind of waiting move right
because you just put the question to
Black you keep the pawn on D5 where it
keeps the keeps the Knight imprisoned
and as Robert would say don't let the
equal email bar fool you it's an evil
evil evil bar here right because black
is maybe a blunder away from from
blowing it if the d-pawn gets loose yeah
because as we were just showing if black
plays A2 which is such an obvious move
that's the movie you want to play you've
been pushing your ape off the board but
you put the pawn of square where rookie
two is such a nice move because black
was defending actively The Rook on D3 it
stops the d-pawn from running up the
board at least doesn't make it so easy
and it protected the pawn on A3 which
freed up The Rook on eight if you have
to play Rook D3 to A3
Brooks love being behind past pawns
right that's usually the dream but now
when both of your Rooks are behind the
past Pawn because now your Works have a
defensive task where whites Rook on E2
in particular it can do both it attacks
A2 so it sort of make sure that blacks
Works aren't free it's a bit defensive
but at any moment it could spring free
and go to E8 or E7 back there the d-pawn
can run so
in fact instead of A2 if we just go back
a couple turns there to after H4 like
black can play H5 and say well I pass it
back to you on passant will lose the
game because your knight out of six is
lost and if you don't take on poisson
it's like well your turn what are you
gonna do now the one scary thing about
playing H5 is you allowed H4 and G5 to
remain and the reason that's so
worrisome is we've seen these
checkmating patterns that Knight on F6
if you get the F7 Pawn or you get you
know Rook to H7 or G8 with a king on h8
it's going to be Checkmate so these
mating patterns exist and you don't have
H6 to try to Chisel at that pawn
structure white wants to keep the pawns
there black doesn't really want to allow
it but another thing this opens up is
Knight H7 where at some point maybe you
want to get rid of that pesky Knight
especially if that Rook drops back to E2
let me trade away that great knight get
rid of it and also keeping the pawn
stuck on H4 means that white can never
open the H file if King G2 H5 Rook H1
maybe a surprising Checkmate pattern and
maybe black can play Rook A4 and go
after that pawn so there's a lot at play
here where both sides are sort of
jockeying for options for positioning
and both sides are actually risking a
bit whenever pawns go forward they're
going away from some of the other pieces
and both sides will have chances I I
just want to point out a funny draw I
just noticed okay again in this Rook C1
move or after H4 H5 we can include this
and if I were to play Rook C1 here A2 I
just noticed this Rook takes F7
almost Checkmate versus seven Knight D7
nice only move you've got this take King
f8 and black is promoting but white has
the known well-known pattern called
huh I have no idea what that's called I
whether this has a name yeah that's
actually really funny because you think
there's so many night and Rook patterns
you know like the Arabian maid or
Anastasia's made but this is just the
you know this is everyone refers to it
as you know that pattern with the rook
in the night yeah
this is our chance if this hasn't been
named before this is our opportunity now
to name it call it the the Hess
Championship no definitely not should we
call it Bobby special Bobby fresh
I I don't even remember having this I
haven't asked yet what should we name
this particular Knight and Rook pattern
where the Knight defends The Rook
precisely because it is a knight jumps
away in fact just to really show why
it's a pattern if if this Rook for
example were on a square like C7 and you
were otherwise losing okay here you
would be sometimes the move if it was on
white would be to play Rook D7 just to
put the Rook within the knight's grasp
so that this particular pattern forever
now known as the Fabi fresh
Bobby's looking fresh I I don't I don't
want it to be named
it all right that that pattern would be
would be a rather funny one quite a
silly way to end the game I don't think
we're going to see it I do feel like
we're going to see H4 for some reason
just because it seems like such a Magnus
move put it back on Jan H4 is right now
I could see Magnus making that kind of
draw yeah because he likes trolling and
he likes sort of funny chess moments and
like that is a draw and it's pretty cool
actually it's like play Rook C1 get rid
of your rook in front of that past pawn
and then just to sacrifice a rook to
make the draw let's let's see what
happens with it again there's just to
show everybody because Checkmate if not
yeah black is actually checkmated where
he stands if the Rook was on f8 rather
the night that was the checkmate but
again I uh I won't call it the Fabi
fresh
um and if we go to h8 we should just
show that check maybe yeah that's the
pattern we keep talking about yeah and
it's you know best seen over the board
that this would be checking with Rook H7
so that's why we keep some of the danger
of leaving the Knight on F6 is that
black can walk into various checkmating
ideas because of that pattern but yeah
this is we see Magnus he shuffled there
a little bit then he leans over and
makes the move well 98. this doesn't
mean anything in particular because
exactly he's repeating once and he might
he's lower on time so he might just want
to get to the time control
um one move faster
so that that would make sense
um yeah I was just gonna say that we we
talked about this point earlier if you
see the repeating Don't Panic everybody
because it just means that their players
are getting closer to time control and
you don't want to you don't want to be
the one who needs time on the clock I
did see one name for this which I liked
from the chat yeah which is the pendulum
the pendulum
I like that
I like it too I thought I said that I
thought it didn't quite catch you
whoever said the pendulum you get a one
year Diamond membership courtesy of
Bobby on a car wanna hit up hit up our
boy trim or any of our helpful mods uh
speaking of our boy trim helping helping
lead Our Community Management shout out
to the whole crew working super hard we
had a question for you earlier uh
courtesy of the the fact that you're
about to give a lesson here in a few
days for a private group debuting our
feature classroom the question is do you
follow a specific pattern when you can
when you consider a move
it's interesting I already kind of want
to say the answer is going to be no but
is there is there a checklist is there a
way he asked whether you're following
some sort of tree while calculating or
maybe I'll just ask generally do you
have any tips about keeping your thought
process organized when you're when
you're deep down the calculation rabbit
hole Yeah there's
um let's say the recommended way is the
tree of variations okay
um based on first finding candidate
moves okay I mean going through them
um there are downsides to this which is
that uh let's say you you just go
through them mechanically uh like almost
robotically you just find your cam your
candidate moves and then start that one
either reject it or not go to the next
one but that wastes a lot of time if you
start with a bunch of bad moves and you
actually had like a really good move and
if you had started with that earlier you
would have saved a ton of time
um I think that most players follow a
much more chaotic pattern which is they
see a position
they might see a bunch of moves that
make sense immediately and go through
them but they might go through one for
like two minutes and then be like I
don't know if what I think about this so
I'll just move on to another move and go
through that for a bit and then move on
to another move or they just see a move
that they like immediately
and then don't calculate anything else
just stick with one move which has its
pluses and minuses plus it saves a lot
of time
uh especially if it's a good move minus
well you might miss other options if you
if you just consider this one move other
potentially better options shout out to
the chat chess um Meryl Mary who gave us
that question
can't quite read it from here but thank
you Robert I will say that this answer
this question is very situation
dependent because if there's a position
where it's a bit more neutral and there
are five equivalently good looking moves
right you start sitting and thinking
whereas if it's pure calculation where
it's like okay I'm thinking about going
for this night sacrifice you're going
down variations within that night
sacrifice and trying to figure it out
and actually a very good game that
illustrates this point is when you
played alireza farrugia who went on to
win the fide Grand Swiss in your game
you you won but he was spending a lot of
time in the early stages because the
position was really just unclear that
there were all these different potential
Pawn breaks and it met so many pawns on
the board their pieces it was a kind of
locked position at first and you start
thinking is this the right strategy not
the right move which is how you should
think about Chess but as five minutes
and you burn a lot of clock whereas if
it's a wild Affair and you've you're
saying I'm going to sacrifice my Rook on
C3 in a dragon you start thinking about
like checkmating patterns and you're
concentrated on one specific area of the
board rather than everywhere when the
position is a little more neutral
interesting obviously there's all kinds
of books have been written on this just
you know obviously the you know how to
think like a grand master by kotov is a
famous One how to think in chess of
course there's all kinds of tips that
someone like Fabiano would continue to
give especially if you were maybe one of
the lucky 10 people that takes part in
his private lesson coming up on December
13th so uh play along just by all you
got to do is solve one of his video
lessons and tweet or insta-proof of it
with a screenshot and you'll be
automatically registered to win 10 of
you are going to be in a private lesson
and get everybody in that in that
session we'll get at least one question
answered from Fabiano so all right the
question of whether this game is going
to end in a draw right away will be
answered soon I don't think so Magnus
played the move 98 and then Knight F6
check I will remind everybody as we get
closer to time control what the move
numbers are we're on move 31 right now
so we still have nine moves to make with
Magnus about to get less than 30 minutes
on his clock uh so nothing serious right
but just a little bit of insurance when
you play tickle with the King there
right just to make sure you get one move
closer your thoughts on what Magnus will
play here because I don't think he'll
play 98. he doesn't want to play 98 for
sure but he's probably a bit disturbed
by how he's getting lower on time and
yeah probably not finding something
which really satisfies him on the other
hand there is really no point in playing
Knight yet if you're going to do a next
move so if you were to make a move like
H4 and Blackboard to play H5 as Robert
mentioned or another move you could
consider your options again but you
could always play 98 or you can choose
Rook C1 if you want that draw so um I
hope if he does decide it's a job we get
Rook C1 just so that everyone's happy
we'll analyze again uh what Bobby was
saying that H4 is
probably the move
at least to ask like what he wants to do
the problem is he would love to play H6
to just trade off that pawn to make G5
weakness again but then 98 yeah we
talked about that King G8 G takes H6 I
don't know if this is necessarily bad
for black but uh it feels better well
he did lose I mean why is threatening to
win on the spot with Knight F6 but who
knows maybe there's Knight H7 then
covering some squares but at least black
um it was given tough decisions odd
position Knight H7
is now uh rotates device isn't
immediately a threat because there's
still a fork on C7 but you remove that
Knight F6 check so at some point white
will be forced to directly protect the
pawn rather than tactically do so and H6
is kind of a scary move to play well
yeah I think that HERO Black has an
immediate threat of King f8 which is
super uh double attack annoying to deal
with
um and also like renews the idea of A2
if you get if you get too distracted
yeah why no longer really well it's a
clear meeting up H6 would be a spicy
move but the thing for from White is
that after h4h6 he can he can still
repeat if he wants oh yeah just just a
little tickle this is always available
for him so it doesn't make sense to
repeat at this specific moment
unless as you said you want to conserve
energy
yeah
well at least you can let your opponent
calculate and make him use his energy
um
but yeah I have a feeling he might
actually be calculating instead of H4 D6
okay D6 96 and D7
it's just a very direct way I mean he's
threatening rookie eight
um
I was wondering exactly how black deals
with this one can you play Knight takes
G5 yeah that's what I want to play yeah
takes D7 even yeah Rook takes eight King
F6 I I don't think that this is
immediately very equal because white
takes the A3 pawn and B if there were no
B pawns it's a draw yeah but because the
B6 Pawn is a weakness and Rook D5 Rook
B3 keeps the white B5 Pawn this is not
an immediate draw
um
net is yeah the return of the mating net
from the other side down
but so so I don't know I don't think
black would go for this I don't know
exactly what
um
I mean it's not very clear of how much
of a thread rookie 8 is
you know black has like
Rook I was going to say with the 1996
you can just put the Rook on d8 either
before or after rookie yeah Rook da
rookie it might I don't know the Rook
takes D7 you know maybe Rook d8 is
on G5 okay not right away but I'm
looking at just at the end of those
lines where the Rook comes to D5 and
suddenly everything might be falling
um yeah so he's probably looking at
lines like this wrong with this is of
course he starts to take risk here
because he no longer has a draw so he's
committing himself to this really great
idea and then I don't think he wants to
open up this uh possibility of a third
result
hmm
okay so then my best guess would be that
he plays H4 we've looked at D6 we've
looked at H4 you're still thinking H4 is
the most likely
way to pass the buck back to yawn at
least if he sees that A2 rookie 2 looks
dangerous for black
um
it's a good idea
to do this uh because it gives black a
chance to go wrong and yeah in the best
case black plays a a neutral move like
H5 and we're in a similar situation to
the previous move
yeah but I could also play your crazy H6
but yeah yeah or H6
um if black plays like Rook A4 trying to
take that H4 bone I think it starts to
get very dangerous for him
right right away yeah uh yeah just to
take H4 interesting I think D6
now
because uh we mentioned this like D6 if
96 is rookie eight right so so yeah now
the Nike is a mobile nf8
uh black yeah okay it would be would be
a real nightmare so you have to be
careful about that yeah this is win for
white so
I mean he can like take H4 but it's very
greedy it's difficult to decide on that
you know Rook A4 D6 root takes H4 yeah
it's tough tough to play like that so
at least D6 gives black a decision to
make uh sorry H4 gives black a decision
to make
and there's my face on screen again so I
have to pay me to attention the chest
once more but in this H4 move it does
put the onus on black for the time being
and the question I have remaining in my
head is at what point does Magnus say
all right there's nothing left to do
here because the biggest danger is when
you're in this mindset of how do I maybe
play for a win how do I keep the game
going there's no risk for me but then
you missed that moment where there is a
slight risk and then you now you're on
the defensive whereas you've been the
one who had the draw at your disposal at
any moment and like wait there's some
issues here and then I don't have this
98 Knight F6 and you will very likely
have that available to you right but
just something to keep in mind because
as chess players when we get in a
position that seems dominant there are
moments where we just don't recognize
that we don't really have so many
winning chances in fact it's our
opponent that if the game is continuing
they're the one who suddenly has more
needs to win so it's such a danger it's
one of the most dangerous spots to be in
was a position where you had no risk of
losing for a really long time yes right
because the switch Yeah that switch is
really hard for the defensive player
often to use as well because when
they're defending like I'm not winning
this game then there's like that moment
where everything flips and you need to
say here's my chance I'm not just making
a draw anymore let me put the pressure
on you and Magnus himself is amazing
when he goes from defense into offense
you have to watch out but I think
sometimes when the pressure's on you
you're the number one rated player in
the world it's the world champion you
want to get that win your Knights on F6
their Checkmate patterns all around that
black pawn shouldn't go to A2 too soon
you're thinking well there's nothing at
play here for black yeah but you should
always always think maybe my opponent
has a chance you need to be skeptical of
your own position you have to give your
opponent credit and you just have to
calculate every turn and Magnus is doing
just that he's spending a lot of time
here because he wants to make sure that
if he does continue here he'll always
have 98 Knight F6
but then it gets back to the question of
he's really burning a lot of energy
trying to find a win you and I have
talked about this a lot with students
the way to the way to keep that mindset
alive is we always say well if it was
really just a draw the game would have
been agreed to or you if you're the one
defending you say well if he if he
really didn't have anything then why is
he still pushing right because you have
to keep yourself Vigilant right and who
who else Fabi is we talk about Magnus
Carlson as being
maybe maybe the greatest ever when it
comes to capitalizing we'll call it on
the turnover right the most exciting
moments in in sports Rob and I talk
about this a lot are the turnover where
offense becomes defense or defense
becomes offense right who else would you
say is very good at making sure they're
always on the edge of their seat to
capitalize on an opportunity
well I think top players in general are
good at that in terms of
um
let's say there's I think there's a big
difference between uh turning the
tiniest bit of Advantage into uh into a
major advantage and eventually winning
the game and Magnus has shown us time
again that that he does that extremely
well and finds chances from nothing
um then there is the counter-attack
going from a bad position and and
turning it around first uh saving it and
then turning the tables and I think that
Sergey kayaking is is a good example of
it okay he very often
um turns bad positions around he's very
tenacious a lot of it is actually
psychological because like Magnus is
um ability to make the most out of
positions is it is of course in many
ways uh his from his fantastic strength
and and his chest ability a lot of it is
also that people tend to uh give up when
they feel like the game is headed
towards a draw or well usually people
don't give up when when they're losing
they try to find every last chance
because nobody wants to lose but very
often people just acquiesce to a draw
and Magnus almost never does that he
always looks for the slightest chances
unless he feels like
he's going to run risk if he does that
but when when there is an absence of
risk for him and most people would just
go for the draw he he keeps his guard up
because he knows also that people when
they feel like they're coasting to a
draw sometimes get very careless
uh so
so a lot of it is mindset as well as
chestibility
how's Fabiano caruana at that
at uh how would you rate yourself as far
as
um I think that I I learned a lot
actually from from playing a world
championship match and that I you never
let your guard down that was one of the
things that I learned because I had to
defend a lot of tough positions
um like the match is remembered for all
the draws but I had a lot of slightly
scary moments not just the like let's
say the first game where I was dead lost
but a lot of positions where I had like
a slight Advantage from the opening and
I messed it up a bit and turned into a
slight disadvantage and there were
I think many many moments in that match
when I felt that happening so I I had to
learn in general
to uh to defend worse positions and one
of the ways you do that is by Never Ever
Getting careless uh especially against
Magnus
well yeah good stuff and I'll say I
think one thing that you do very well in
particular at least in all the
conversations which are many we've had
about Chess is
there are plenty of positions where
maybe one side is better but you kind of
wait before being definitive about it
which I think is really healthy because
if you're super definitive that oh white
is better in this position then you kind
of lead in with a bit of bias you're
trying to justify your Viewpoint rather
than calculate step by step the ways it
goes and I think that as a commentator I
try to do that as best I can where I'm
like you know the position that you've
ever may say something and if you're
playing you don't have the eval bar
you're disposable but it's really
important to always sit there and be
like you know this does look good for
white but how good is it what happens if
these pieces are traded so is it really
that good for white because that trade
seems to be inevitable and so you just
start putting things in a bit more
perspective rather than just stopping at
the basic point this is good for
somebody why is it good how can that
Advantage be gone and we see Magnus play
the move Knight EA check
that's what time number two here it
might be a sign that he does think the
advantage could slip in this game if he
wasn't careful and that also he just
loves proving me wrong when I'm on
camera as I said I don't think we're
going to see 98 we're going to see him
go for something and uh Magnus is like
ah come again after King G8 he can still
play H4
okay let's hope let's hope against hope
here that that's not what we're about to
see
um well regardless of when this game's
and this game ends let me remind
everybody that when the game is ending
our show is just beginning we are always
joined by amazing special guests right
at the top of the hour we give you a
full recap of anything you may have
missed if you happen to have tuned in
late uh all kinds of things await you as
our post game show gets rolling today we
have Harry Mack freestyle rapper
extraordinaire on the show
and all kinds of people around the
corner so anyway just remember that
don't go anywhere we got a lot of
insights ahead and
and this game may not be about to end
we'll find out in just a few seconds
here
he's played Knight F6 check and so
that's already three that's already
three I think Jan will probably call the
Arbiter right now
yeah yeah indeed he turns and is doing
that and I and the reason for that
everyone for those who haven't maybe
played over the board chess is before
putting the piece on the Square the
threefold repetition rule uh must be
claimed before the third position occurs
once you played the third position it is
actually considered the opponent's move
again so they have a chance to change
the nature of the game
yeah d696 pretty soon
foreign
yeah
yeah okay true I'm even here okay 4D
promotes
yeah
V6 at some point it should be okay maybe
I can yeah
but they also had like interesting move
from like 96 and it's 87 38 it's all
kind of Carol cage and an H6
and some parts not so easy
I mean maybe there's just a necessary
session
I mean the rookie8 you can also take on
this island yeah I mean okay a lot of
those but I mean maybe you can keep B5
phone I wasn't sure yeah
[Applause]
those two players really wanted to talk
about that game Magnus was not
yeah he seemed disinterested it just was
like you know I don't know what's up
this is just a draw and Jan was they're
talking about some interesting
variations there and I think for
everyone watching it's pretty hard to
pick that up yeah but you know over here
sitting using yeah I think that we can
translate what they said pretty quickly
yeah which is after King G7 all of
magnus's time was spent let's say if
black plays king g70 or the position
they had oh what Magnus was thinking
about was D6 which we kind of suspected
that was the case 96 D7
and the first line they mentioned was
Knight takes G5 Rook T8 and Rook to A4
oh wow and uh Jan thought that after d8
Queen Rook d8 Rook d8 King F6 Rook D6
king move somewhere
Rook takes B6 followed by Rook to A6
white might have some chances but Magnus
was a bit unsure and it does look like a
draw
and then you answered that black can
probably play instead of Knight takes G5
Rook to d8
uh and Rook to E8 and Magnus said well
at at least well I can just play where
it takes D7 but Jan mentioned we have H6
as well yeah
um yep yep okay wow well that game did
come to a close quickly um let me remind
you real quick before we before we give
you a full recap of the game for many of
you who just tuned in we're about to
tell you everything that you missed but
coming up uh at the within about 15
minutes we started our run a very
special guest giving us their thoughts
on not just this game but the match
overall bit it Gujarati is at the top
India's super Grand Master also a great
streamer when he chooses to do so on
YouTube Harry Mack our freestyle rapper
the guy bringing you bringing you our
pre-game hype daily and then John Ludwig
Hammer who of course brings us the hype
from Norway but without any further Ado
it's time to review game four in our
coinbase rapid recap and that begins
right now
all right so
um
so yeah we
we started out with with the Petrov
yeah it was a surprise for us I'm
guessing also a surprise for Magnus
although he did play quickly and he had
something in mind
but still he couldn't have expected that
Jan would play an opening that not only
he's never played before but that he
he's never even played
similar lines like this before yeah it's
it's a totally different from what he's
uh traditionally played but it made us
excited because we have Fabiano caruana
with us in the studio in case you missed
that memo Bobby we have Fabiano caruana
Bobby and Bobby caruana knows the Petron
better than anybody and the first point
that he made Robert was really that
right here the move 5d4
was was either a showing of in hindsight
we learned that maybe Magnus didn't have
anything because we've talked a lot
about the fact that Knight to C3 is
probably where the more Rich variations
lie yeah well I might disagree slightly
with that statement he might have things
in sharper positions but he hasn't
looked at them as recently as Jan has
okay so there could be a fight for an
advantage but if you take a sharper line
against somebody who is just recently
looking at with his team of seconds and
his engines and all that preparation
that goes into a match like this then
you put yourself at a huge risk so he
took the safer approach no tactics
pieces aren't flying across the board
instead he said let me try to nurse a
small Advantage if I can get one it
wasn't meant to be yeah and if of course
we see a picture up again I'll say I
agree with with Robert's disagreement of
what I said and that I think we probably
I think we probably would see Knight C3
a second time now that there has been a
huge reveal in this match which is hey
Jan who doesn't normally play the Petrov
well he might be playing the Petrov in
the 2021 feet a World Chess Championship
bout we played a lot of theory here
Bobby was predicting the main line that
all occurred on the board stop me when
you want to Favi but this was this was
all Theory here yeah this was known to
both players in general this is a very
known position and we were speaking
about it early on in the game and
looking at some of the possible lines or
White can take on B7 with the queen and
things get a bit sharp and crazy yep uh
but Magnus chose a different approach a
more calm one where he uh yeah a more
positional approach rather than playing
Queen takes B7 he played B Tech C3
well we'll we'll just show real quick
the one of the key points of these lines
everyone is that even though the Rook
Falls on on A8 things like 94 takes and
queen D7 lead to tons of incredibly
sharp lines where this queen maybe
doesn't ever find safety again and so if
you you want to see the full details of
that either look up the theory or even
just replay the beginning of our show
okay B takes C3 was played B6
yeah I think we mentioned after cd5
Queen B5
uh after Queen D7 White had two options
um one was the one move he played A4 but
the other one was to take on D7
immediately and this would have been a
slightly more direct approach and now to
play A4 and 2 uh to play it more slowly
and uh
I'm wondering if
um what Magnus did was a bit too Direct
okay and again a lot of things you were
highlighting as the battle becomes about
the week C3 Pawn versus D5 but again
what Magnus did was the more direct
approach A4 Robert
and we saw right away that Jan was
prepared when the queen trade in A5 was
played and part of the reason this is
more direct is because it gives black an
obvious Edge on the queen side this Pawn
A5 is a protected past Pawn whereas in
the other position with the pawn still
on A4 for white the C3 Pawn is going to
remain a Target no matter what but here
black has a second Plus in the position
and that's the outside pass Pawn so Jan
knew exactly what he was doing at this
stage he was playing quickly he was
taking some time but he was playing
confidently and well and I think that A5
he knew it and he was able to secure and
position without any disadvantage
hindsight is 20 20. so anyone who's been
here from the beginning is going to say
wait in the beginning of this you guys
were saying Knight H4 what a brilliant
novelty well and to be clear it was a
novelty this was the first move played
in the game that had never been played
before and it was that Magnus played it
and then quickly played G4 that had us
kind of excited the long-term ideas
Bobby highlight them in terms of what we
initially assessed as potentially
magnus's positional positional maneuver
here yeah I think we were super excited
G4 happened because it's both a very
unusual sequence of moves Knight H4 and
G4 looks like the exact opposite thing
of what you want to do right like all
the actions on the queen side
but you're doing some stuff on the king
side weakening your Pawn putting your
knight on the edge yeah but it was
obviously a deep idea he had
um the issue is that Eon also seemed to
know what to do unfortunately for all of
us uh it quickly turned into a position
where white didn't really have many
chances and I think we'll tell everybody
what the Deep idea is for white even
though it didn't work out yeah so the
Knight is rerouting for it looks like a
great now on F3 but it's not really
doing much so the Knight is rerouting
itself to E3 potentially or to F4 where
it attacks white Black's only weakness
in the position which is the D5 Pawn
which is a very serious weakness
um the problem for white is that he has
his own weaknesses C3 as we saw was a
very bad weakness and uh black is saved
by this past a pawn uh the position we
got in the game yeah as Robert mentioned
before this pass a pawn is black Saving
Grace here
well Rook to C8 was played and it was so
we were we were jumping out of our seat
a little bit Knight H4 and G4 and then
when Jan played not just 97 but Rook C8
quickly you noticed something what you
both did you notice I'll start with you
Robert that okay he must also still be
okay because this is a big moment which
works should you put on C8 a or F should
you move the Knight to F6 first right so
playing a move like this quickly was
kind of revealing right it certainly was
because the way this position becomes
the dynamic is different it is level by
objective evaluation but it's not
symmetrical and it's not exactly
balanced black has this outside pass
Pawn the a pawn white has this Pawn on
D4 that eventually started pushing up
the board so there are things to think
about for both sides because you're
playing on different areas although both
sides of the past Pawn they can March
them a little bit but not all the way
and they were able to maintain the
balance
and and obviously after Brook C8 Bishop
before we didn't have much else to look
at and and in hindsight again being 2020
we were already calculating lines that
probably probably uh were the best
variations for both players to go for
yeah the problem from White's point of
view is that he's really forcing Black's
moves here uh if black doesn't take on
F4 and take on C3 he risks losing yeah
so uh Jan's decisions were not too
difficult and I think we quickly noticed
that this line would Rook takes C3
Knight D5 Rook D3 is Black's best bet
maybe Rook to B3 is is also a decent
move uh and it looked like Magnus was a
bit surprised by Rook to D3 so maybe he
was more ready for Rook to B3
uh
but it didn't seem like he could cause
Beyond any problems in this position we
were already struggling to find ideas
for white here yep in hindsight
is there something to Rook B3 Robert you
pointed out something really crucial
about the world coming here which isn't
just hitting the beep on it's that if
this Pawn does make it to A2 there's
Rook to B1 in a lot of positions
protected by the pawn your thoughts on
whether this could have been mounted
anything I think it could also land
black in some trouble as well because
the pawn on B5 can't be captured because
there's always this Fork on C7 so The
Rook on B3 it attacks the less relevant
Pawn that white has the d-pawn is what
white trying to push up the board so
there are some circumstances where you
give up B5 and just keep pushing your
Pawn forward and with a knight on F6 a
rook on E7 like we saw in the game this
could be really dangerous for black
because it's not about Pond quantity
it's about quality black may be getting
a little bit greedy but White's Pawn is
just storming up the board and that
could spell some serious disaster for
black all right well it makes sense then
again in terms of why Jan played Rook D3
here come the forcing lines rookie seven
Knight F6 check you guys were already
pointing out that anytime Magnus wanted
it he would have a draw with 98 check
and of course the reasons there are that
the king can't really Escape without
making matters a lot worse for himself
in variations like this so on that note
we saw one repeating
then we saw a move D5 Pawn is of course
poisoned due to the fork on F6 but it
was all at this point as you were
pointing out Robert maybe just a Magnus
Bluff there was nothing to it yeah I
don't think it was a bluff but he's he
you can't win a game you've already
drawn and so Magnus has done so well
over the years winning positions at most
other top Grand Masters would just have
agreed to withdraw 10 moves earlier he
is Relentless in putting that pressure
on you and because he goes the distance
every time you can't let up as the his
opponent so I think it's a good decision
because it's not just about this game
it's about the match as a whole Magnus
is saying that I am going to fight until
I just don't see anything left and we
heard them after their game finished
they were talking back and forth Max
like hey there's nothing there I'm just
going to repeat the time is now to make
the draw but it's just showing a little
something that he wants to fight
whenever he's given the chance to
any other comments on this on this
moment here G5 supported the night but
after A3 we know what we saw which was a
repeating of moves and the draw any any
last thoughts on something Magnus could
have done I think that magnus's last
chance they were discussing D6 and this
is the most direct approach and
um it doesn't quite work out in terms of
proving an advantage yep maybe H4 would
have still been a bit tricky
um
I keep mentioning this move and of
course it's not like it really changes
the evaluation it would still be equal
and I think Robert mentioned a good move
in response H5 but at least it couldn't
have hurt him to try this and I'm a bit
surprised that he went for the media
repetition I think he he was calculating
D6 for a long time uh let's show one
more time why it's nothing special d696
D7 and Jan mentioned move Rook d8
they're also talking about Knight G5
which might also be good but Rook d8
seems even easier and here black has no
real problems to speak of uh so I think
Magnus spent all his time looking at
this these kind of lines
and then he was low on time and he
didn't really want to play a position
and potentially take a risk being low on
time for the rest of the game so so he
repeated which is a practical decision
under the circumstances
um but yeah it it feels a bit like
um this is overall this game is a big
success for yawn a surprising Magnus in
the opening
um I don't know if we'll see Magnus
return to E4 at least for the next few
games with white
um if he was refers to E4 he'll need to
have something big in mind because I
think that Giannis shows his shown his
intention is to play the petrol I don't
think that he's gonna be switching
openings with black he showed very good
prep and understanding of the position
uh and of the opening as a whole so I
think most likely Magnus will try to
probe in in other lines in the closed
openings maybe with D4 maybe with Knight
of three on them or C4 on the first
moves well you you already answered what
was going to be my final question is how
should the Challenger be feeling right
now but you said this game that should
probably be seen as a big success for
Jan and his team clearly surprising
Magnus and Magnus not getting anything
despite having white on the rest day so
all right that was our coinbase recap
let me remind everybody that we have the
Recaps available to you daily on our
YouTube channel we also have the
highlight are in dramatic Fashion on our
YouTube channel and tons of interviews
coming your way from my client over on
our new YouTube channel chesscom live uh
go head over there hit the Subscribe
button to make sure you're alerted
because more events will be streamed
live to youtube.com chesscom live than
currently have been and it may be the
place for some of our some of our future
events exclusively so all right let's
remind you that we've got tons ahead we
have guests we are about to tune in live
to the post game press conference as we
do every day but we start off the top as
you see there with bitter Goose rothi uh
after a bit it top Super Grand Master
from India we will have Harry Mack the
freestyle rapper Who's uh bringing
bringing it to you daily again in
freestyle fashion we're going to have
Harry rap for us freestyle we prepared a
few words me and Robert and Bobby
um we didn't give him the Hess
Championship we might have to throw that
at him uh but we've got some words that
Harry's going to have to respond to in
real time and then of course we also
have young Ludwig Hammer who joins us
daily gives us the thoughts from Norway
I'd be really curious what he says today
given how disappointing this was for
Magnus with the white piece of course
all that matters is who wins the match
in the end but yeah we all predicted a
win for Magnus right and it and it
didn't happen so we'll get we'll get
Hammer's thoughts in terms of what he
saw all right chess.com is now post game
coverage of the 2021 vide World Chess
Championship is brought to you by
coinbase and it returns in just a moment
foreign
ER Grandmaster Yan napomnishi relatively
short day at the office do you think you
surprised him with the petrol for we
should definitely call it the Russian
well so you know since I can't have my
Russian flag here at least I can't play
Russian uh in a game yeah but I guess he
wasn't quite surprised so he went for a
very
very long enforcing line which is
uh I believe for those who dig deep into
the petrol lately they uh these people
should be familiar with this line but
I guess uh which was more or less the
first line of
Giants till the very end you may have
said some unofficial record for least
time at the board today of course you
were waiting to see if Magnus was going
to take all these repetitions so what
were your thoughts and uh where were you
during all that time
well I mean okay my
goal was simply just not trying not to
mix up my prep so well uh
I believe it's a 40 freeze Motors Force
but black is in time I actually expected
something like rookie C1 into Rook F7
king of seven rookie seven brilliant CIA
to you know to make a Perpetual check
like this but enite is also of course
the way but uh I'm just was sitting
in my in my room yeah because I mean
there was not so much on the board today
yeah even withdraws there can be
beautiful ways to make the repetition um
and lastly although it would be highly
unorthodox it is magnus's birthday and
you are friends with him is there any
chance at all you'll have a drink with
him tonight
I doubt he would invite me and I doubt
it's the correct moment to drink but of
course my warmest congratulations to him
fair enough thanks to your time thank
you
ah damn yeah check it out check it out
come on I said I'm coming off the top
and I'm spitting the two fly peace to
all the people who be rapping the dude
by tell me how you really think it's
going down play some Jazz man put your
things get in the crown keep it light
here you ain't got no option come on
y'all you know what you're watching we
gonna keep carrying on TJ Chess
Championship on chess.com peace
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that the questions can be asked at the
microphones to the size of the room
please do not touch the microphones and
always at all times wear your mask as
you ask questions and please direct your
questions to the individual player or
players but if you want both to answer
name the one you would like to answer
first
uh Magnus at first I will let me say
happy birthday
and we in that regard what if you may
let us know is your history of playing
chess on your birthday and how did that
possibly affect your approach today or
your mindset today in today's game
um I would have of course loved to have
a rest day uh on the eve of my my
birthday so that I could like have a at
least a token celebration
um apart from that I would say it's
pretty good I think I won at least one
game in the World Cup
um against almonato I believe in 2005
and obviously the match in 2016 was
decided on my birthday in the in the tie
break so it's gonna take a lot to for me
to have bad Recollections of me playing
on my birthday even though I lost lost
to uh to uh so last year
uh Jan did this matter to you at all
that it was magnus's birthday the chess
players have superstitions uh your
experience on your birthday and how that
might have affected today yeah
absolutely I uh okay my my big goal was
not to forget to congratulate Magnus
yeah
uh I mean at least after the game yeah
so once again congratulations
uh but uh as for me I think it was very
different so I I believe
in childhood I played a few games uh on
my birthday but it was
I mean it it never was easy or something
yes so in general
I think
trying to recall this in the memory it
was like like some another game and
yeah normally it's only effects of that
you are basically having no party
because uh because uh yeah you know
you're going to play the next day or
something
Magnus uh this is your second white
today
your expectation about the Petrov it's
not traditional opening that Beyond
plays were you surprised at all by it
uh no it was one of the main openings
that I've expected seeing that he played
it in the in the in the candidates and
also
um in the first black game he um went
for uh for a more classical classical
approach rather than than a sharp one so
it was very much uh much expected
um couldn't know obviously which
exact petroflani was gonna he was gonna
go for but um
Petrov in itself was very much expected
and your feeling about the opening you
got
I'm what can I say I tried something
concrete uh and um it didn't work but
that's I think
normal normal results
um
I didn't expect him obviously to have
to have missed the line that I played
completely but yeah in some other
iterations there can be a lot of
difficult decisions to to make for for
black but I think yeah the way that he
he played there was just there are some
different tries but there's just nothing
and
state of state of modern chess not much
else to say you did though at the end
look like you were working like overtime
sweating to try to get something at the
end look you look like you were really
trying very hard before you finally
stopped
uh why was that
um I I think
um
it sometimes happens uh at World
Championships that you work you work a
lot before the before the match and you
work a lot during the match and openings
and such
and somehow this makes you work less
over the board my Approach was very
clear there that I didn't think
particularly that I had had anything but
I
I have two hours for the game so I
should spend them all uh looking for
whatever chances can can be found
yeah and did you feel like you were in
any difficulty at any point during this
game
well the actually the line which
happened is I guess uh should be known
by many who who play petrol yeah so it's
one of the lines which are quite
principle
uh despite this I believe Knight is 4 is
very interesting try but uh perhaps I
even wanted to play this as white one
day yeah well uh but in general yeah the
task was more or less about not to mix
up things here and not to I don't know
and not to do something stupid because
uh as far as I know this line is more or
less to say so safe for black so uh of
course I was checking twice everything
and also calculating a lot but in
general yeah I think this is quite safe
draw for this game satisfying result
well since I played Petrov indeed
and for you Magnus uh second white took
a shot but again a draw is this at all
frustrating or is still early in the
match no it's okay
um I've started with
a lot more draws than this earlier and
when you play when you play a forest
line as
as today
um you um you don't expect to
uh to hit very very often but the idea
is to
um to hit once in a while take your
opponent by surprise and the other times
you're you're usually going to be very
safe
um so um
yeah I I
would have would have loved to to win I
would have loved to find more chances
than I I did but I think overall yeah
it's uh it's a normal result against the
well prepared opponents
we'll take our first question from
reporters in the room please well I'm
only from the chess24 global broadcast
of course the entire chess 2014 wishes
you a happy birthday and Magnus my
question is for you I'm sure that chess
fans all over the world hopes for you
how that you can go out and celebrate
and have a very nice birthday will this
be possible for you or do you have to
just work work in order to prepare for
tomorrow
um yeah I'm playing playing tomorrow
um I feel like the general idea of world
championship match is that you celebrate
after you've hopefully won that makes a
lot of sense
yeah
Sagar Shah from chasevis India my
question is to Magnus first of all happy
birthday uh you played the moon night H4
which was a first new move there were
games until A5 and then uh Nepal's moves
were pretty Sim like straightforward G6
and so on so what were you hoping for
with uh like in which situation would
you have
um
there are there are insanely complicated
lines if I mean the the the approach
that he chose is not the only one
that black and black and truth and in
other
um another variations it's insanely
complicated and um
really really risky for um for for black
uh and
to be honest the one he chooses
um it looks
really really risky to Leave the Night
On f8 and Bank everything on on the a
pawn if you've miscalculated something
you just lose without without any
without any chances
um but
it's a lot easier of course when you've
studied it and you know that it's a draw
and you can kind of work it out from
from there but believe me there are many
many other other options
um
for for black that lead to that lead to
much more complications than than what
happened in in the game
um
so uh I I think what he did was just
very very sensible
um
an approach that looks
a bit dubious at first since you're
you're not going to be locked in but
with um you know with concrete
calculation you can you can make it work
and that's
that's uh that's how you usually solve
solve your your opening problems you try
to uh to avoid the lines where you have
to
remember everything and try to choose
something that you can
you can sort of remember them
the main points from
myclimatechess.com my question is for
Grand Master Magnus Carlson as the
journalist Corps continues to speculate
about who your seconds are and I'm sure
you're too kg to reveal you've done this
so many times before can you reveal
what's the tenor in your Camp is it
pretty normal from the first four uh
World Championships to this one or do
you notice your team uh perhaps with
different emotions about your openings
and how what kind of positions you've
been getting
um
yeah so I don't really understand the
the gist of your your question uh I
think
um people have
people have emotions of their own uh
those those who work with me for me
um but um
I'm the one who has to play after all so
their emotions are
um if not unimportant they're not really
a relevant Factor
um to me I would say so far
um there's very very little to to report
in any case
hello Rakesh from chess.com Magnus
firstly a very happy birthday we've seen
four draws but how did it go on the rest
day in the soccer or basketball
um
yeah so I um
I was on the winning team the whole time
in in football
um
don't know if they they threw
intentionally uh if they did I don't
really care
um
but
uh definitely definitely raised my
spirit so so that's good
Norway happy birthday to Magnus um a
question for both
um is this the best way of deciding a
world champion or could it be other ways
of doing it like
for example the FIFA World Cup way or as
an ordinary uh chess tournament or
whatever
yeah
well it's hard to say because
I believe uh their importance of
traditions in chess
is really big and uh I guess
whatever works you shouldn't like try to
to make it work better yeah I mean not
in order not to break it so I believe
this system with them matches is more or
less Fair
uh but uh I mean of course it has some
obvious drawbacks because it's like not
being played yearly and and so on yeah
but I mean uh well it's you know we can
discuss it like uh the whole night
Magnus
um
uh there's uh there's a saying that if
you don't have anything nice to say you
shouldn't say anything at all uh so I'm
gonna invoke that particular saying
right here
hi uh Saron I'm from chess base my
question to Ian
when you played A5 and the Magnus played
Knight H4 pretty fast
you showed a look of surprise on the
board
were you not really expecting this was
it part of your preparation
well uh I only think I knew that this is
uh I mean
even without let's say analyzing his
position it's obvious yeah that playing
Knight H4 and letting the pawn only one
E5 here as opposite Pawn which is
protected well by Pawn on B6 is quite
risky so that's what you can figure out
without preparation but yeah fortunately
I you know knew the idea and more or
less you know more or less I could
remember what to do
so I mean of course I was kind of
surprised but because
I mean
this is one of the to say so Sidelines
but it's yeah it's very principal at the
same time yeah and it's it's better to
uh it's of course better to remember
your most instead of finding them you
know
out of the board
uh if I can follow the tab uh you played
Rooker C8 after a minute thought or so
till that point also did you go by your
memory or did you come up with on the
board
well uh I guess uh I wasn't quite sure
what was the correct move after 98 check
immediately King h8 King H6 or King G8
but I remember that King Jade is also
just fine and then okay uh I believe
more or less until the last move it's
uh I'm not quite sure but I think uh I
have seen something like this
one my question is
foreign
uh What uh
sell them
um
is over the past sort of few years you
know we've seen you make big strides and
big improvements and I've noticed sort
of a change in your opening style and I
think you've been known to be sort of
like a very sharp player maybe utilizing
some less classical opening choices but
recently with the Petrov and other
choices I'm trying to understand
is this change in opening style do you
think this has been critical to your
recent success
well uh basically it doesn't match what
do you play if you if you know what
you're doing yes so well in that case uh
I mean
you could name basically one of like
three or four very solid openings with
black and uh
if you let's say study them by heart
uh you can be I believe more or less
successful but I mean speaking about my
uh more or less recent results it's more
about the general approach uh other like
picking some particular openings
and if I may continue what Magnus said
about the football he played yesterday
you know as as uh one of your opponents
do you think that anyone was afraid to
go too hard on you
if there were an injure you because I
certainly did not want to be the guy who
injured you uh before the the next day
yeah it's it's an interesting uh it's an
interesting question
um I think a lot of people would indeed
have
um have that mentality that they would
not want to to injure
um you know somebody
um
like important to to a lot of a lot of
people uh I played with some
professional footballers in my life
uh and my Approach then was very
different like I I always felt it would
be a fun story if I
injured them if when they played on uh
on their on their spare time
um and um
um yeah that's so I always went like
extra hard uh against uh against them
um and um it gave me uh gave me an edge
because it forced them to to shy away
instead so a little tip there yeah I'll
try to give you more of a challenge next
time but uh thank you
happy birthday and question is actually
about your birthday because I don't know
if you know that Winston Churchill was
born the same day as you and do you
think you have something common with a
former Prime Minister of Great Britain
the first question or maybe you remember
some of his quotes or expressions
um
yeah
I mean there was this quote from
Churchill and one of his opponents I
think that he was a very modest man and
he had great reasons to be modest uh so
I would say for my opponent that he's
not a modest man and with good reason
today on his birthday
I mean just to enjoy what is he doing
and like be healthy happy lucky and you
know all the best
a question for you on uh how is this
championship match going uh according to
what you planned are you playing better
Wars or according to plan
I might probably tell this when the
match will be over
well we have two more questions please
michaels.com question again from Magnus
this may sound like a silly question but
it's actually quite serious a lot of
athletes when they get into their 30s
the recovery time is lessened and I've
seen you play sports during World
Championships for three or four hours at
a time so does your body feel any
different after these rest days when you
do a lot of sports yeah it's really it's
a really good question
um
there were
um well there was one person in my team
yesterday who had one task and one task
only which was to pull me away after uh
um you know set number of of matches so
that I would not
um not be be too tired so that's
certainly something that I'm I'm
conscious of
any more questions
please Magnus in the end you were
thinking for 22 minutes for Knight F6
also 34 minutes could you share some of
the lines that you are looking at like
were there some opportunities
yeah I was
um was considering a lot of things
um like D6
um King G2 followed by my Rook rookie
eight uh also Rook A2 followed by Rook
E3 after Rook B3
um but um yeah black just seemed to to
hold uh hold uh everywhere I guess D6
was um kind of the um the most obvious
way to to try and find something but I I
didn't think it was close
we just have one more question from the
feed HS Twitter page uh you can send
your questions in and you may uh get
hear them here on the air Magnus to you
do you plan on sharing any of your
birthday cake with Team nepo
foreign
yeah that's uh that's a weird question
um
first of all I don't know if I'll have
any maybe a little bit tomorrow
um
but um
I I I think with the history of world
championship matches I don't think you
would uh accept any piece of food from
the opulsing team ever
with that we conclude the press
conference thank you ladies and
gentlemen tomorrow's game will be at 16
30. it will be game five thank you and
have a good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
launched a YouTube channel this is
chess.com's post game coverage every
single round of the 2021 video World
Chess Championship and speaking of that
guy Vida Gujarati we have a special
guest here what's up BD
hey man welcome to the sofa with me I I
see you guys been tweeting about the
sofa boys are you happy to be a sofa boy
here
uh I I think this is the closest I can
get to you know being on the sofa so I'm
happy I'll take you know we'll take what
we can get to we're super pumped to have
you man and love the poster behind you I
wish I was coached by VD
um anyway man
okay there's been four games we've had
four draws obviously we all know high
level chess often has a lot more than
meets the eye we know there's a lot
going on there that maybe sometimes
doesn't happen that said where do you
sit on the storyline of the match so far
if there's any momentum who do you think
it belongs to at this point and your
general thoughts on on what has been the
the fide World Chess Championship to
this point
um so talking about the openings uh with
let's say nepo's black games it's
obvious that he wants to go for the most
forcing way for example
um petroff is you know it it's a solid
opening but it's very very concrete
um you know the lines as fabric can tell
you go very deep and you have there are
very long variations and you have to be
precise on many occasions and but it's
very forcing that's the advantage of it
you avoid all kind of Italian defense
where you know you can play like you can
play around with the move order and you
know some tricks like that and it's very
complicated in a different way but
Petrov is more straightforward
um more concrete
um so I think that's the strategy and
also if you notice the game he played in
the Catalan this line with B5 that's
also very forcing you know he's not
trying to get like a solid position
which engine say like it's zero ten or
something he's just trying to go
very forcing like this B5 line if you
can yeah I can see the position on the
board
um Queen C2 B5 A4 I think his point is
to play Bishop B7 and then a b A6 I
think this is very trendy
um so that seems to be strategy and I
think Magnus at least now knows his team
knows that there are two ways like
either they try to find idea in Catalan
or Petrov and I think it will be Petrov
that's my instinct like because there
are more open ends in Petrov than in
that particular line in Catalan so I
think that's where the match will go now
on when uh Magnus is white
and with nepo as white I don't I mean
it he's yet to show something I I would
say Magnus has been playing some
Sidelines he's dodging
um dodging the main lines so I don't
know what will be next will nepo
continue with E4 I think so I doubt that
he'll change to D4 but I'm curious to
see what he'll do against the Marshall
it's not so easy Bobby your thoughts
yeah I think that's that's interesting
what you pointed out about uh Napo yeah
I'm trying to get
um very forcing solutions from Black's
point of view I was wondering what do
you think if if we see that Magnus knows
that's a strategy will he try to play a
different first move like C4 on the
first move to try to get the game into
less forcing Waters
um
it makes sense to try C4 but my instinct
is that in Petrov there are so many
ideas that can be possibly tried like
you know many one game ideas
um maybe he'll not go for this bishop D3
line which he played today but he can
play the traditional main line which is
to take on E5 D6 Knight f394 Knight C3
and here maybe he can try to ask some
questions uh as you know you have played
so many games here uh there are like
countless ideas possible and very tricky
models and stuff like that so I feel
maybe 93 is one area which you can try
uh the problem with C4 is with napo's
game in Catalan I feel he he will have
something very forcing against it as
well like C4 maybe he'll try to play
Knight F6
um and then
um if Knight F3 E6 and then D5 try to
still get into uh Catalan G3 D5
but yeah it's possible I'm not sure
um it's definitely a possibility I have
not really thought about it as much
E4 is more likely that that makes me
wondering about another thing and I'd be
curious to get your thoughts on this
also uh when you play very forcing lines
it hasn't invented early on but then you
might make yourself a Target
uh by playing lines where your opponent
can prepare something very directly do
you think that at some point Magnus will
try to Target very specific points in
what Yan has shown himself to play
um
I don't think Magnus is generally that
type of player to you know I feel to go
for a particular line and you know be
like improve on it again he's more of I
feel
you know him better of course but he's
the type of player who would like to
jump you know test uh in some different
lines and he doesn't generally repeat is
what I feel so the next game whenever it
happens I feel it would be more uh
more in a different direction altogether
interesting but it we've obviously
talked a lot about the opening here and
and at the highest levels of chess the
opening is often where you focus because
the players have the skills if they get
even the smallest advantage to properly
convert it we know that that's a skill
that takes a long time to build but
outside of the opening have you had any
thoughts on on the general form of the
players any other insights that you know
as a
super Grand Masters you look at these
two guys and their form any other
thoughts you've had
well I think they're playing pretty good
level of Chess
um I mean really good level and
um the only thing which is like you know
which is a bit weird is when I see
everyone talking about you know so many
draws happening and you know should we
change the world cycle format and they
ask the players about it I'm sure it's
disturbing them and I think it's just
part of the game you know I think draw
is the most likely result maybe we'll
see what two wins or maybe one win
throughout the match I don't know so
that's the only thing and but I
understand like every fan wants to see
some blood and the my question to you
guys is when do you think will that
happen
that's a huge question I mean I'm
already on Pace to have one of my
predictions wrong which is I predicted I
predict we would have a lot of decisive
chess I just looked at the style of the
players and with Magnus being the
favorite that might lead to some more
pushing which could even in turn open up
chances for yawn but I've been wrong
right and and I think you brought some
great Insight just pointing out how
forcing yawn's approach has been is
black that he really wants to not give
Magnus a chance there so I'm gonna I'm
gonna answer that question by not
answering it into fertafavi when do you
think we'll see the first one well I
think that it's clear Jan has a strategy
and the strategy is to frustrate Magnus
yeah he probably feels that is the best
way uh to get chances long term because
we saw that when Magnus when things
aren't entirely going his way especially
when he's not able to make inroads uh he
he can get uh frustrated and sometimes
he can even go on tilt so I I think
that's that's Jan's hope it's probably
also a very good strategy
um so he's not really taking Magnus in
an open fight
yeah
um but in terms of like the players play
so far outside of the opening there's
not much we can talk about there's only
really the second game that had much
content the the first third and fourth
games were all relatively
theoretical Affairs where they led to a
more or less equal position and in the
first game Magnus had some slight
chances but but more or less we only
have that second game as an indicator of
how the players are actually playing
outside of the opening
I'll say this video I will be shocked if
we do not have a decisive result in
classical classical chess I'll be on
record to say I just I don't think
that's going to happen and what are what
are your thoughts on that
yeah yeah I agree definitely you know at
some point the pressure will build up
you know they will get tired so mistakes
will happen
um as Fabi pointed out not much has
happened out of the opening because the
positions which were like very forcing
for example today nepo just had to push
the a pawn like he didn't have much
Choice
um and in the second game I feel Nepal
missed a chance right it was a
um it was quite a big chance when you
look back at it
um
and the C3 move in that game completely
puzzled me yeah
I was hoping to I was hoping to see
Queen E7 and I was speaking to my father
and I said no no that boy is going to
win as way too ambitious uh so but I I
honestly felt that this is not the type
of question Magnus would really feel
comfortable uh second game you know
World Championship you're materially
down and you could be in serious trouble
here
um but I feel this was a big uh chance
missed because C3 I mean he could have
put pressure uh somehow like the game
could have
maybe it would have ended in raw but he
would have put more pressure but after
C3 tables kind of turned and he was on
the defensive so I I felt that nepo has
had more of the chances in the match
just looking at this game yeah
interesting and definitely agree that
the of all those all the maybe missed
opportunities this has to be at the top
of the list so far and and we saw nepo's
response after that in the post game
press conference that he was nervous
right revealing some nerves so well the
last most important question is this is
also the first day of the world Hess
Championship
um how do you feel about Robert hess's
performance so far as the main
commentator for many of chess.com shows
um I don't know if you can see my shirt
but the Hess Championship I don't I
don't know that Robert has really
performed up to the task so far but your
thoughts on Robert's performance
well you know he's a friend so I have to
be nice I can definitely say that uh he
has upgraded his wardrobe because
whenever I did commentary with him it
used to be on usual speeches
championship and he would just put on
the first shirt he could find first
t-shirt
and I see now in him in jacket you know
well groomed so I can say that
definitely his presentation skills are
much better he was always a good
commentator but yeah he has found a
scope for improvement I I agree and it's
nice to see Robert put in a little bit
effort to his wardrobe agreed so anyway
man um you know if you if you want I can
get you one of these shirts um what you
know or maybe even a mug for the world
has Championship so we'll talk about
that later
um but uh your your webcam is looking
great by the way I want to remind
everybody they can follow you not just
on Twitter but also your YouTube channel
your your stream you're still streaming
from time to time and uh where else can
people find you yeah
um I think YouTube is the best way if
they want to see me um do something
which I'll regret later on uh and if
they want to reach me then it's
um I mean I don't really look into DM so
but yeah uh Twitter and Instagram with
the chess it's everywhere but yeah I
actually streamed last stream was I
think I played the title Tuesday and I
might do it tonight all right man well
um it's great to see you and maybe we'll
maybe we'll get to catch up with you
again later later on in the uh in the
World Chess Championship but thanks for
bringing your thoughts and we'll wish
you wish you a good evening and maybe
see you again in a later round
all right that was the one and only a
bit of Gujarati again you can check him
out on YouTube follow him on Twitter and
uh he's definitely an entertaining and
worthy follow uh if you're looking to
add add another top Grand Master with a
big personality that you can follow on
social media definitely do so all right
we're gonna we're gonna take we're gonna
take a break here um I can't wait to uh
well you know what actually one second
before we take a break
because this this might be the last time
we have you right here
your thoughts on what he said there
about that was a really interesting
point about Jan's forcing approaches
black I want to get your Insight on that
before we let you go yeah I think that
Jan has changed his approach many ways
and it started with the candidates that
is clear we could see there that he was
trying to take a more measured approach
a bit more solid
um
taking his time more not not doing
let's say
irresponsible things over the board and
here we see that he has uh
basically completely changed how he how
he's
approaching the match uh he's he's
playing new openings super solid and
forcing lines
um as we did mentioned the Petrov is
it's a very Illuminating choice because
now we we kind of felt in the second
game that he's trying to force the issue
a bit in the opening but the petrol is
really uh showing that and I think it's
going to be a very uncomfortable choice
for Magnus he has to find ideas I'm sure
that he and his and his team will
um but it won't be easy and
the interesting thing is of course Jan
has to not only neutralize Magnus but he
also take his chances in the second game
he wasn't able to do that and I don't
know if maybe he wasn't ready so early
on in the match to have such a big
chance but he was objectively either
winning or very close to it so
uh I don't know if he really looks back
on that game as as you know a missed
chance or or with some regret
um because his his two games after that
were both pretty stable and confident uh
but objectively he did miss a big chance
yeah next chance that comes he needs to
be ready to take it
it's interesting how will he handle his
next chance and of course it also adds
to the storyline of if yon is okay with
just a bunch of draws and frustrating
magnets maybe he is looking forward to
the rapid tiebreaker in a way that maybe
maybe some of magnus's previous
opponents weren't so interesting stuff
for us to continue to unpack as both
players are revealing their strategies
don't go anywhere because after this
very short break we will be unpacking
all of young Ludwig's Hammer yawn Ludwig
hammers thoughts from Norway as Robert
Hess rejoins the show and we and we
catch up with hammer chess.com's
coverage uh post game coverage of the
2021 fide World Chess Championship
presented by coinbase returns in a few
minutes
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be larger oh
Magic
magic with music with architecture weird
colors magic with celebration with your
safety From Here There and Everywhere
for six hormones day and night join the
making of a new world starting October
1st
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys who's here
Robert
is here no way it's here dude hold on
hold on
and boom
we did it yeah baby
is the world has
Championship
that's what I'm talking about this one
has the copyright C where is that Danny
but you get it look at it look at it
you'll see you'll see here there's a few
others
the design things nice here I want that
one you see it Bobby you get it now no I
have no idea what no his face there's
missing C's all right
Robert you want to explain it you know
my name the game you play It's called
chess right and there's no word
Championship it's Championship so
there's a c you know
yeah yeah no
I mean I think it's I think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this no I don't think
anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest you've ever
seen in my life
oh holy
if you think it's too late to send it
back I ordered a lot
[Music]
if anyone's wondering it actually is too
late to send it back
to hammer right now
video have you ever seen Fabiano Carr
want a curse like that your thoughts
well favi's reaction just made the whole
thing didn't it that was so good who
knew that Fabio car wanna
um you know what first of all did he
did he that he hated the merch so much I
mean I was shocked by that
um but the you know the way he expressed
himself also just very aggressive so uh
a guy that expresses himself well every
day when he joins us as John Ludwig
Hammer uh today for a game four
breakdown that um most of the storyline
seems to be kind of momentum a little
bit in yon's favor right now in regards
to how how he maybe maybe surprised
Magnus with the Petrov but either way
seems to have neutralized a little bit
of the world champion when he has the
white pieces but Hammer maybe you have a
different view or what are your thoughts
I think it was a great game by
nepalnyachi but I think
um the fact that he revealed at the
press conference after the game that
pretty much everything was preparation
that made me breathe a sigh of relief
because there was a moment there where I
thought nepalnyachi had played this
incredible defensive effort almost
without thinking uh and and just played
perfectly in what must be described as a
carlsonesque kind of position
um so I was I was kind of scared about
Magnus magnus's chances in the match
moving forward if napomniachi was able
to neutralize a typical Carlson Edge in
the manner he did however when he
reveals that it was all preparation it's
like um yeah it's it's not great to give
away your white game but at least you're
not facing an opponent who learned a
couple of Tricks uh and and who has
expanded well beyond his attacking
reputation uh but also uh
if he hadn't prepared everything in
advance it would have been one of the
most dis spectacular displays of Defense
if I'm reading you right you're saying
that you'd be more afraid of the man
than the machine because with the
preparation at some point you'll catch
him off guard but if he is elevated his
level to the point where he's playing
just like the same quality the same
style as Magnus that would be what
Magnus would fear most am I reading that
correctly
yeah I I think that's a good summary of
my stumbling words yes no no thank you
it is it is a great Point Hammer because
obviously that's what we have to do at
this point is is try to read into to
what what the players have done in the
preceding months before this match right
and we don't know until we're here and
then we see what openings they've
prepared but I want to go back to one of
the first things you dropped in your
response which was the fact that John
has revealed something not just in terms
of the fact that it was all preparation
but has revealed that the pre that the
Petrov is something he prepared very
hard on right so let's talk a little bit
about that do you think Magnus expected
Jan to go to a Fabiano caruana special
if you will with the Russian defense and
do you believe Magnus will maybe go back
at the Petrov now that his team has some
time to think about it
um I think Magnus is a very honest guy
so when he says at the press conference
Petrov is one of the things they kind of
thought were the most likely uh then I
believe Magnus uh in that I I think
Nepal nechi was just brilliantly
prepared today and he handled magnus's
choice of of opening line very very well
um so credit to him I think for Magnus
this game was just about well it wasn't
just about it but part of magnus's
ambition going into this was figuring
out what
um had planned against the King's Pawn
opening after Magnus had checked the
queen Pawn opening in the first uh White
game and now that Magnus knows what he
can expect if for the next time Magnus
has the white pieces he will choose the
one one where he thinks he has the most
chance to make nepomichi crack
um I think it's going to be the Catalan
because I think Magnus has poor memories
of trying to take down the Petrov uh in
his magic against Fabiano Carana back in
2018.
um so I I think the the fighting ground
will be in in the Catalan and I think
Magnus got some answers today about
where the match is going to take us in
the next
yeah I think it's really interesting to
hear your thoughts on that because in
the 2018 World Chess Championship when
Fabiano caruana was playing as Magnus
Carlsen when Magnus was black we had the
same opening every time but the
variations differed but when Magnus was
white we saw Magnus try his hand at
different openings now there's a
difference between this match and that
match in that janapam she already
ventured into new territory in game
three when he had the white pieces
versus how he played in game one so I
guess my question is now from the minds
of the Challenger uh in your belief do
you think that Jan should keep going
back to the same first move because he
did play C4 in the candidates speaking
of different openings played there so
what do you think Jan should do as he
gets the white pieces tomorrow
that's a tricky one because Magnus with
black so far has been very comfortable
um and and Jan hasn't really been able
uh to challenge uh Magnus uh there
um
so I don't really know I'm glad I don't
have to make that decision because it's
a tricky one I I think he needs to move
off what he has been doing I think these
strategic uh Spanish rule Lopez
positions are just very well suited for
Magnus because if he gets out of the
opening there's so many pieces remaining
on the board that Magnus can easily
outplay even a strong opponent with the
black pieces so I I feel like I've been
very surprised with how
um napomniachi hasn't been going for the
forcing variations that he wants to play
chess and that he wants to
um take take on Magnus in a strategic
duel
um and I mean it's been working for him
so far but I can't help but think that
he should go for something uh a bit more
direct and I have said before the match
started and I still feel this that the
jababa Italian opening uh should be
um should be a territory that is
explored by nepalnyachi but if I if
that's my first guess you can be so sure
that team Carlson has been checking that
opening as well so there's a balance
between being direct and and
counteracting with with trying to be
unpredictable at one point today in the
post game press conference Magnus
answered a question with if you don't
have anything nice to say you shouldn't
say anything at all because he didn't
want to respond to what is now probably
to him feels like three World
Championship matches really with with a
lot of draws about the format I'm asking
you Hammer because you know you know
Magnus well and obviously I don't want
to dive into the formatting question
which go ahead well I I
I I think what Magnus said is very
easily misinterpreted and misinterpreted
because I think he was directing his
comment at the journalist not at the
format because they got the very same
question uh on Sunday and so I thought I
think what happened is that Magnus
didn't have anything nice to say because
if he were to say something you it would
have been that they shouldn't be asking
the same questions every single day so
I'm I'm not sure that was directed at
the format itself it is well known that
Magnus has been speaking about a format
a different format than the one we know
today but he was I think it was too
cryptic what he said to
um be certain that that was funny to be
clear I just you know I was going to
agree with you and actually say that
magnus's frustrations are probably more
with the fact that he's been hearing
these questions so much than anything to
do with the format right and so I was
going to ask you you know does that
weigh more on Magnus you think than yawn
because this is yawn's first rodeo right
and obviously he doesn't have any
problem and in some ways with the
longest world championship match
possible and and a chance to beat Magnus
even if it takes to Rapid but do you
feel like Magnus is going to be
frustrated if he continues to have to
deal with these questions that from his
point of view are kind of rightly
ridiculous right he's like look I win
the world Championship with the formats
that's presented kind of lay off me
right so what are your thoughts on as
the match goes on if he keeps getting
questions like that from journalists and
how that might rattle him or not
I I think Magnus is way too experienced
to be rattled he's been facing dumb
questions from Norwegian reporters more
in for more than 10 years he's very well
prepared to deal with it yeah Fair yeah
well I have another question for you
Hammer because the what we've seen so
far it's been a bit of a back and forth
affair with both sides showing good
opening preparation particularly with
the black pieces what do you think it
takes for one of these sides to get past
the other because right now it seems
like they're both brick walls with black
so Jan gets the white pieces in game
five that's supposed to be an advantage
I sort of as you said called your bluff
uh two days ago when I said hey
sometimes playing with white is a
disadvantage so I'm gonna put you on the
spot do you think the first decisive
game in classical chess if we seen one
is the player winning with the black
pieces
um
it's it
it's a very difficult question
um which is why you're asking it so that
you yeah you caught me immediately yes
um I um I think it's been very random
that we have so many draws in a row uh
in the world championship matches I I
think the the match between Magnus and
Fabiano in 2018 was one of the most
exciting there's ever been and and yet
every single game ended in a draw but it
it's about how it ends in a draw right
uh and uh as a big fan of Chess myself
uh I I thought that match was thrilling
I thought the game one and game two in
this match was very very exciting we
also saw several situations when Carlson
faced karyakin where Magnus repeatedly
had positions he should win but then
failed to
um like hammer in the the last nail in
the coffin uh so I I feel like it's very
very very random that we've seen so many
draws now lately I I think
I I think
judged the the judge the the games not
the scores and and I think the the the
the game good advice quite exciting good
advice I like that judge judge the game
not the score
don't hate the player hate the game
um Tupac lives or something like that
okay that was great uh hammer uh if it's
even if it's been random that we haven't
had decisive results it was not that
random that today was the launching of
the world has Championship so your
thoughts on Robert hess's performance in
general as a commentator he is currently
the only
reigning and ever world has championed
but your thoughts on on Robert Hess as a
Hampton and as a champion okay sorry
your thoughts then go ahead
I had the pleasure of doing commentary
with Robert this full and may I say he's
a model professional and uh I like to
think we are two of the the top people
in in our fields of uh of Chess spoken
like a true Hampton himself maybe you
start paying me you'll love it
well I aspire I I Aspire when's the
Champion yeah we love that well thank
you thank you hammer for bringing
bringing the noise every every time you
join us and uh it's it's one of the one
of the best parts of of our broadcast
daily so really appreciate you man again
we'll let you go we will see you
tomorrow after a game five and who knows
what we'll be talking about but we'll
know then and uh we'll expect you to
bring it
bye yeah see you around all right and as
a hammer a true Hampton himself
compliments for for Robert Hess leaves
us let me remind you everybody that our
trivia answer is coming whoever played
along and quote tweeted the answer to
our question uh won themselves a
one-year Diamond membership and you can
do so daily just stay on the edge of
your seat look for it to be revealed uh
Jonathan corblood brings it to us every
single day remember that Jonathan corbla
is the voice of chess.com's new
documentary chess a reflection of us we
will be debuting episode three uh in
today's broadcast uh so we'll we'll talk
about that after after the break and on
the other side but stay tuned for both a
repeat of the question if you missed it
and the answer on the other side of the
break
[Music]
thank you
hi Jonathan korbble again here in Dubai
at Expo 2020. Dubai has a rich chess
history first hosting an Olympiad in
1986 however never previously hosting a
World Chess Championship
which city has the record for hosting
the most World Chess championships
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
thank you
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 v-day
World Championship is brought to you by
coinbase whether you're an experienced
Trader or just looking to make your
first crypto purchase coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free Bitcoin just for
verifying your account today
[Music]
foreign
lighting and audio
we're going to crush through the top of
the show
[Music]
all right
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could do more but I guess
we are doing some insane amount of works
I hope we we get to be
[Music]
ready enough
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
here back with the answer to our trivia
question which city has hosted the most
World Chess Championship matches well
that would be Moscow with six and here
we are in front of the Russia Pavilion
at Expo 2020.
ah yeah yeah check it out check it out
come on I said I'm coming off the top
and I'm spitting the two fly these are
all the people who be rapping the dude
by tell me how you really think it's
going down place your best man put your
things get in the crown keep it locked
here you ain't got no option come on
y'all you know what you watching we gon
keep carrying on feed day Chess
Championship or chess.com peace
[Music]
welcome back everyone chess.com's post
game coverage of game four from the 2021
feet a World Chess Championship
continues our coverage is brought to you
by coinbase and right now our coverage
is bringing you the one and only Mr
Harry Mack the guide that's been kicking
off every event with the uh with the
sick freestyles Harry it's an honor and
a pleasure to have you here man
yes honored to be here with you both man
thank you guys so much I got I got your
boy Robert Hess here I know you guys you
guys have become friends you've got you
you've done some chess we've got a lot
of questions for you so I just want to
set the tone with we're going to keep
you here as long as possible no I'm
kidding but we are going to keep you
here for a while and and we're gonna end
the show so everyone knows with a with a
a freestyle in real time for Harry our
team is ready with words that we've
secretly prepared over the last day or
so to to hit Harry live on Discord uh
when the time comes but you don't know
them yet just sit there and sit tight
we're gonna do that in a little bit
um Harry you uh you came into the chess
Community a few months ago you competed
in our POG champs for now that you've
been here for a little while tell us a
little bit about how was that experience
playing in POG Champs how's your
experience been with chess are you still
enjoying the game and and your thoughts
on just uh the chess Journey that has
that has now began for you
yes yes yes uh my chess Journey has been
very enjoyable I was thrown right into
the deep end obviously because I'd only
been playing chess for uh you know a
month a month and a half uh before I I
played my first game in POG champ so
that was needless to say very
nerve-wracking but also very exciting
and uh you know I got to work with Hess
so I had a great coach uh I got to you
know learn a lot very quickly and sort
of like a crash course kind of uh all
right Harry let's let's at least get
some basic skills ready before you uh
play in front of thousands of people
um but uh but not since the tournament
man I've continued to play chess and uh
I I really do uh love the game I'm
really really grateful to now uh have a
very basic understanding of the game and
I'm excited to keep learning and growing
as a chess coach he's not here so just
tell us how he really was tell us
well I I can see that he's there next to
you unfortunately but
um nah amazing Coach man uh yeah shout
out to Hess thank you so much bro uh I
I'm excited to uh hopefully I gotta get
back in for some more lessons man I'm
ready to level up Harry the first time
we did a lesson I remember you were new
other pieces move and that's about it
but we had a really interesting
conversation and I asked you you know
how does your rap background help or
hurt your chess learning you want to
share with everybody what your initial
thoughts were about how you're thinking
about rap impacts your thinking about
Chess
yeah absolutely so in the beginning
I kind of felt like my freestyle
technique didn't really align with what
I was needing as a chess player so I
almost felt like it hurt me a little bit
uh in the beginning
um because what I mentioned to you is
that the way I put a freestyle together
is very linear right it's like a leads
to b b leads to C C leads to D and so on
and so forth so a freestyle can either
be a short and sweet eight bars and I'll
end there or it can go for 10 hours
continuously but wherever I'm at I'm not
thinking about where I'm gonna be in
five minutes or 15 minutes or an hour
later right I'm just I'm kind of like
right in the moment right where I'm at
and I felt like with chess you know it
was important for me to also have a big
picture view you know and not just be
completely in the moment you know where
you where you end up like we talked
about tunneling it or focusing too much
on on just one thing that's that you
feel is happening right in the moment
but actually uh assessing the game at
sort of a a big picture level thinking
multiple moves ahead and sort of
creating a plan and a strategy so in the
beginning I felt like my freestyling
kind of hurt but actually now that I've
been playing more and more there are
some Concepts and some things that are
sort of dawning on me now where I kind
of see how how uh you know how they
relate to freestyling you know
freestyling is all about this setup
punchline concept and uh often in chess
you're kind of setting yourself up to
make a capture maybe one or two moves
later uh so I don't know now my my tune
is changing a little bit I think the
freestyling might actually help me
you're gonna actually be worse as a
freestyler that's what I'm worried about
here
nah man I I hope not you know obviously
uh you know the Rizza is a chest but
Avid chess player all the Wu-Tang uh
members are Avid chess players logic is
a is an avid chess player I'm sure I
follow those uh you know incredible top
tier MCS uh we're also uh you know
learning chess throughout their lives
speaking of Bobby speaking of logic uh
Harry he had he had high praise for you
when he was in studio a couple days ago
uh and and we asked him you know he did
a little bit of a mini freestyle but we
asked him you know how do you how do you
guys do what you do what are some of the
things that go into being a freestyle
rapper I mean are you just are you
reading you know the dictionary and the
thesaurus says like all day or or what
else are you doing to kind of improve
your your rap game
man uh great question uh first of all
shout out to logic that's super dope
that uh that that he had uh those kind
words man he's he's obviously a legend
and somebody I respect a lot so
um now I I've actually never read the
dictionary or the thesaurus or or done
that I know a lot of greats have
um but you know I I don't have the
attention span to do that and I I don't
think the information would stick I
can't learn that way I'm better with
like stories and you know I like reading
books and and then the information will
stay with me because there's like a
narrative or a story in sort of a
greater context but in terms of just
reading through the vocab uh it wouldn't
necessarily help but but for me the
thing that
um the things that are the most helpful
are one daily practice you know I have
various exercises that I that I work on
and I'm always creating new exercises to
sort of push the boundary and challenge
myself and I've been sort of obsessively
practicing freestyling since I was you
know 11 or 12 years old I'm 31 now so
for about 20 years I've been obsessed
with practicing and over time my
practicing has become more structured in
the beginning I would just freestyle
because it was fun and now I create
actual challenges and exercises
um and then the second thing is is
listening to uh the greats you know
that's probably the most important thing
is is
um you know uh uh music is a language so
whatever style of music you're trying to
master you have to immerse yourself in
the language it's like you know the best
way to uh uh uh to to learn Spanish
would be uh potentially you know to move
to Mexico and live there and be with the
people and and have to speak that
language on a daily basis
um and so that's what you have to do as
a rapper as well you know I I listen
deeply to
um Nas and and Jay-Z and and Biggie and
Eminem and all The Usual Suspects all
the all the greats uh I try to absorb
their language so that it can become a
part of my idea what you're talking
about actually resonates a lot with
chess play yeah because even the best
chess players in the world they do
puzzles they do things that will help
keep them sharp but they also have a
team of seconds trainers who Point them
in specific directions so you said you
listen to all these great rappers who
influence you but you have people that
you talk to say hey can you check I just
did this freestyle what'd you think
about it where can I improve like you
have direct sources that can help you
better your freestyle rapping
man that is a great question
um in terms of like an MC that like
mentors me I don't actually have that
um but I have had uh you know rappers
who I respected and looked up to
um you know throughout my throughout my
life who who you know I've sort of been
able to turn to and I think one thing
that's cool for me is you know so much
of my
um content exists on on like YouTube and
and IG and sort of public platforms
where um you kind of get feedback
directly from the people which uh can be
I was gonna say it can be a toxic thing
sometimes you got to keep a safe
distance from it but at other times uh
it can be helpful depending on uh you
know who's who's who's sharing their
feedback you know everybody is a Critic
nowadays so you have to uh like I said
maintain a healthy relationship with it
but I do enjoy getting feedback from
people and and honestly just recording
the freestyles and having the tape to
review has been a game changer for me I
feel like you know it's like every NFL
team watches the spends a lot of time
with the tapes you know and watches back
the practices and the games and tries to
assess oh you know it's one thing to be
in it in the moment but it's another
thing entirely to actually step back and
have a bird's eye view and create a bit
of space between you and and and the
recording and that has revealed a lot to
me you know
um so I I enjoy studying the videos and
and saying okay here's what I need to
work on here's maybe a bad habit that's
formed accidentally over time that I can
work on removing and things of that
nature the again there's a lot more
comparisons there to chess right
reviewing your own games learning from
your own mistakes also learning from
what you did well and and then trying to
build upon that right I mean you're and
it's talking about learning from the
greats as well that's also another thing
that every great Champion does Magnus
Carlson has talked a lot about his
studying of the Masters of the past so
fascinating Harry I wanted to say that
right one of the things I've been
wondering and actually one of my kids
asked this question so this kind of
comes from them by the way shout out
when you gave them a shout out they love
that but yeah when did you figure out
that you could freestyle you started
you've been in music for a long time you
started as a jazz drummer or or maybe
you still are but when did this when did
you start doing it was it just like
walking around the house folding laundry
and and it happened or or when did you
figure out that you had this skill
yeah basically I mean I've I've always
been musical I used to play Rhythms on
the high chair tray and as a as a baby I
would like you know vibrate whenever
music came on in the living room and
things like that so my parents
recognized that I was kind of a musical
guy just you know from the beginning and
I started playing the violin when I was
seven I started playing the drums when I
was 10 and that's right around the same
time I started writing my first Rhymes
and then I started trying to learn how
to Freestyle when I was 11 or 12.
um but the thing for me is I didn't
really realize that I can do it
um my first freestyles were not very
good at all I really think you know we
don't have recordings of them thankfully
but uh but if we did uh honestly I kind
of wish we did because I think uh it
would be it would be cool to play those
recordings and and hear that
um you know there was nothing really
special about them there was no
indication in the beginning I don't
believe that I was going to become you
know known as a freestyle rapper or or
be able to make it my full-time career
um really what it was is we were just so
obsessed with it you know as little kid
kids and you know 11 12 year old kids I
mean we were going over to my friend
Brady's house every day after school and
and uh watching you know the freestyle
Fridays 106 in park we were watching
Rhapsody the basement
um you know music videos whatever I mean
we were just we were really really
obsessed with the energy
um of hip-hop music and and in
particular
um just an emcee and a mic blowing
people's minds with no pyrotechnics but
just the words coming out of their mouth
I mean that that to us was just unreal
and so we were just trying to grab a
tiny little piece of that energy for
ourselves if we could and we were
struggling and falling on our faces but
we just kept getting back up and doing
it again because we couldn't imagine any
uh anything that would be more fun so um
all of the skills and techniques that I
have I kind of developed over time and
learned through practice uh I I think I
have a knack for improv in general like
you mentioned I'm a jazz drummer and I'm
always making up voices and making up
stories uh for better or worse and
annoying all the people around me uh no
but uh I I may have a knack for improv
but uh I definitely
um developed my techniques over time
amazing man and uh someone who also
annoys a lot of the people around him I
can relate to that so um I really really
appreciate that well you know um guys we
could we continue to do this for hours
but I I've also just been given the list
by my team I'm I'm ready I know you're
at some point gonna gonna launch a beat
for yourself so you got something to
flow with but uh I don't know uh I don't
know if you're ready I'm yes I'm kind of
ready to start throwing some words your
way and and see where the uh where the
magic of the day takes us yes for those
of you that have stuck around you waited
for good reason and if you're unless
you're watching this on one of our later
videos on one of our YouTube channels
then you're welcome for for some magic
that's about to go down so um how are we
gonna do this
um you're gonna get the words
yeah you know what
yeah so I I I I the list just dropped
into my Discord here but um I think it
might be more fun man if you yell them
out yeah yeah let's do it
yeah all
because that way people will see that
you're lobbing up to me I'm gonna do it
and I've actually got we'll keep it
zoomed in on me here I I got him here I
was gonna reveal him this way so we'll
start
you want me to start with a word or you
start the beat how we do this
oh that's perfect oh that's pretty you
got them right there oh that's that's
even better so let me just let me just
Spotlight let me know so I can see that
we're big here okay let's see let's see
hold on one second one second there we
go
boom okay nerves all right dope they may
do a little bigger on my here we go I'm
gonna drop my Beats
yeah come on hey hey one two one two
yeah yeah one two one two ah yeah one
two one two
yeah hmac representing here on chess.com
come on uh yeah come on uh yeah yeah
listen I said I grip up on the mic then
I lyrically serve I feel comfortable
I've been getting past my nerves yeah
every time I rhyme I be dropping it
heavy rappers getting nervous in my
presence they getting sweaty yeah every
time I rhyme man I'm making them soak I
can tell that they nervous I be hearing
them go when I rhyme off the top I'll be
letting them bars flow them hard flows
trying to be a legend like Marshall hmac
I'm cold as the win to win God all my
enemies trembling I'm feeling like I'm
Eminem I'm getting lyrical y'all know
I'm spitting it raw I said I'm about to
win the game so it's never no draw yeah
but y'all know my lyrics are for the
handle and if I were to draw it'd be
something like Van Gogh Pablo Picasso my
Styles the amp is hang me all up in the
loop when I'm feeling the canvas any
competition y'all know Mac about to win
I'm making heads been every time they
spit in this cringe hmac yo I'm all up
on the mic so sick that I vomit they be
writing cringe in some of my comments
I'm like chill y'all know I got the
freestyle skills and lyrics I deliver
they'd be one in the mail I got bars
they couldn't measure and I'm lasting
forever y'all know I even respond well
when I'm under pressure I'm never
slipping y'all know I'm about to make
them all on this so bad while I'm
reading all the words lie about the
notepad when they talk about the grace
they bout to mention us and when I use
my mind I'm so adventurous I take you to
a whole new sphere I'm making it clear
eight Mac I kill it when I appear I drop
it major my mind is precise as a laser
and I'll be winning even in spite of my
haters yeah y'all know that I'll be
rising above no haters I open up my
heart and spread love yeah my name's Max
so my flow is immaculate I'm never
slipping cause when I'm ripping my bars
are accurate yeah I'm precise I spit it
nice I don't need no advice I got all
the lyrics short to entice yeah and I do
it for the rapping fans I hope I'm
saying this one right yo it's candelan
this hmake pulling up in the classic
Cadillac winning with the battle raps
and you know that that's a fact yeah I
do my thing y'all know imma flow off at
the top by using the petrol yeah I'm
about to use the defenses too intense
hmac yo I'm about to hit you all with
the dent yo even this last word Danny
would tempt me cause this page is Like
Rappers brains yo it's empty I got this
thieves and I do as I please wait a
minute are you hoping a big whale of
cheese H man come on it I damage tracks
I'm harming songs all my enemies
assaulted like some Parmesan yeah y'all
know I be jumping with no bungee we got
cheese in the stew in case we get hungry
yeah
that I Flow In the Zone they tap my
mobile phone cause I'm getting too much
provolone H Mac yo you know I got the
better Steves I'll Be Clever G you know
we out here stacking up the cheddar
cheese and it's over if you diss me
rappers got hoes and they style like
Swiss cheese
you better believe me like the prop you
held up all these rappers are cheesy I
begin the game I'm a king I'm strong
said I'm moving like a k i n g no Pawn
Yeah Mac I'm the freshest on the scene
and while we added peace to the
strongest piece on the board Queens
peace to the women all around the planet
it's hmac off top kicking Styles
gigantic wow
dude that was Bonkers and I love I just
so I looked in front of me we've got
this we have a birthday basket for
Magnus and for those of you still
sticking around you should because
that's going to be a fun way to bring
the show to a close and I saw the wheel
of cheese so I just grabbed the wheel of
cheese and then you I think you name
just about every cheese I've ever had on
a sandwich there by the end
you know that's my advice to all
aspiring MCS uh make sure you know your
cheese types all varieties no I'm just
kidding that was that was so much that
was absolutely Bonkers and uh
I don't even know what to say besides
thank you so much man this has been this
has been so awesome to have you involved
with with the World Chess Championship
just just uh the the every day starts
out even if we come in here at 3 A.M and
we've got low energy we've watched your
we watch your your crazy raps and and
I'm gonna end with that question then
was that fun for you to do freestyle
raps on on these two great chess players
in the world Chess Championship
oh absolutely absolutely man uh like I
said I'm I am now a fan of Chess and I
am still you know uh very much a
beginner and and so I still have a lot
to learn and so it's it's really dope to
have this opportunity to uh learn about
some of these great players and and and
learn about these really pivotal events
you know within the field of Chess uh
just to just to you know gain more
knowledge and context for myself uh I
love learning in general and being able
to Freestyle about something uh that
I've I've recently become passionate
about is really really dope so
appreciate you guys this has been super
awesome man and I've recently become
passionate about all the freestyle stuff
you do and I know that you have a lot of
fans that you you've won over here in
our community and I just want to thank
you so much for for your time and uh and
for bringing the Rhymes oh my God is it
Rhyme Time Oh no just kidding I'm not
please don't inspiring me yeah
like Harry you
know that's right yeah okay okay okay
all right fair enough Harry thank you so
much man
Talk Sooner my pleasure thanks guys
that was ridiculous I want to just we're
going to be able to because it's
recorded I wanna I wanna go back to what
we did when I grabbed the giant wheel of
cheese aren't you so glad I introduced
you to Harry I'm so glad so glad yeah
for those who don't know the history
Robert and Harry became friends
we completely separate on their own and
at one point we're putting together POG
Champs 4 and Robert texted me and he's
like hey man like like Harry Mack might
you know he maybe maybe he'd want to
play some chess and at the time I'll
admit like a lot of people I said who's
Harry Mack I didn't know well I mean the
backstory is simple he streams on Twitch
and I was streaming and I'd already
listened to his raps and I was just
taken away by how awesome his Omegle
bars are with random people on the
internet give them three words and so I
just watched and then one time I rated
him I read him another time and I just
reached out I was like hey harry I've
read you a couple times I'm a chess
Grandmaster would just love to talk to
you and pick your brain and he was
awesome within a half hour just kind of
just exchanging notes yeah and how we do
what we do yeah and then next thing you
know he's playing chess next thing you
know I'm coaching him he uh is improving
at chess a bit he loves the game as he
said and yep I mean obviously his
rapping is just phenomenal absolutely
absolutely mind-blowing
all right well uh thank you again to
Harry for for doing that thank you for
everything that he's done to uh to help
our shows have an another element and
and another angle and again those those
raps by for for yawn and Magnus and if
you maybe watch those sometimes people
tune in and they don't know that they
were freestyled in real time again they
were and it's just makes it even cooler
as if they as if they aren't already
mind-blowing uh speaking of cool things
I think our chess is a reflection of us
documentaries pretty cool hope you're
enjoying it we're about to Premiere
episode four uh this one continues to
cover The Life and Times of the first
world champion Emmanuel Lasker and his
and sorry second world champion I'm
sorry of course Wilhelm science and I
lost my thought there for a minute but
uh lasker's dominance was real for a
very long time and there was a lot going
on in the Chess World well as he as he
reigned over it for 27 years uh that's
what episode four is all about we hope
you appreciate it stay tuned because on
the other side we have a very special
birthday gift gift for Magnus Carlson
who turned 31 today as Fabiano carwana
rejoins us and chess.com's post game
coverage comes to a close we'll see you
in a few minutes
[Music]
thank you
in 1897 Thomas Edison received a patent
for an early version of a movie
projector
the same year A Young World chess
champion was living out an epic
movie-like Thriller with record-setting
games
stunning defeats and a historic reign of
World Chess domination that lasted 27
years
the story picks up after Emmanuel Lasker
had beaten Wilhelm steinert for the
title of world chess champion
now it was time for a sequel
the rematch would be the first time
Lasker had to defend his title
this time in Moscow
this time around he beats steinits in an
utterly dominant fashion Lasker won
seven of the first 11 games
the other four were ties
steinits won games 12 and 13.
after which Lasker won three of the last
four games to retain the title in a
published letter to the Press
steinits cited a multitude of issues
surrounding his accommodations in Moscow
including overheated rooms the lack of
fresh air and the unavailability of cold
water and ice
however
steinit also claimed in response to the
question why am I beaten so badly
he writes that Lasker was the greatest
player I have ever met
perhaps the greatest that ever lived
fast forward to 1907.
Lasker was studying for his Doctorate in
mathematics and thus had little time to
practice chess his Challenger was Frank
Marshall from the United States his home
would eventually become the famous
Marshall chess club in New York City
despite laskar's studies he crushed
Marshall and held him winless throughout
the competition with games in New York
Philadelphia Washington DC Baltimore
Chicago and Memphis
it was a battle marked by lasker's
employment of the Queen's Gambit and
Marshall's use of the French defense
Marshall in his Mercurial style would
note that tedious play aimed at wearing
down my opponent is averse to my nature
Lasker had no such reservations
Lasker won the first three games then
scored one win and seven draws in games
four through eleven before winning the
last four games
for a final score of 8-0 with seven
draws
a year later Lasker would defend his
title a third time
this time in Dusseldorf and Munich
against fellow German Siebert Terrace
one of the most influential chess
theoreticians
popular writers of the late 19th and
early 20th centuries
game 14 in the match was a nail biter
with 119 moves it held the record for
the longest game in a world championship
for 70 years ultimately Lasker easily
held onto his Reign beating tarash 8-3
with five draws
in 1910
Lasker defended his title twice
first in a controversial match that
ended in a tie with austro-hungarian
chess master Carl schlechter a strong
but sometimes unambitious Master the
players agreed to a best of 10 match
with five games in Vienna and Berlin
respectively the shortened match was the
result of London's Saint Petersburg and
Stockholm all failing to participate in
raising Stakes for an even longer match
unlike lasker's earlier title wins this
Championship was dramatic and well
played by both players
in fact eight of the 10 games were draws
schlechter won game five
the next four games were also draws
in the 10th and final game of the
championship
Lasker had to win in order to tie the
match and retain his title
in a letter to the New York Evening Post
Alaska wrote
the match with schlechter is nearing its
end
and it appears probable that for the
first time in my life I shall be the
loser
if that should happen
good man will have won the World
Championship however Lasker came back to
win the 10th game and retained his title
later that year Lasker was challenged by
russian-born Frenchman David yanovsky
the entire match was held in Berlin and
in terms of the score
Lasker beat yanovsky in the most
one-sided world championship match in
history
the final score was 8-0 with three draws
a true Sportsman chess wasn't the only
game that Lasker was interested in he
was a first class bridge player
and invented a game called laska which
is similar to Checkers
but it's his role as a ferocious
Defender
and a pioneer of chess strategy and
psychology that made him a star Emmanuel
Lasker successfully defended his world
championship title five times
in our next segment find out why there
would be no World Chess Championship for
the next 11 years when Lasker would play
his last World Championship match
[Music]
is is this so here's what we're saying
yes we can discuss it on
[Music]
first game of the 2021 video World
Championship
Emerald lighting and audio
[Music]
we're gonna Crush through the top of the
show
[Music]
all right
am I supposed to feel ready
I guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you could could do more but I
guess we are doing some insane amount of
work so
I hope we we get to be you know
ready enough
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
foreign
F7 where can it go F7 D6 e87h5 G3 E2 C1
V3 white King on A3 white Pawn on B3
black king on E7 who wins it's a draw
Lexington gets to Aid before what's King
gets to be seven name the fastest
Checkmate for White e45 Queen H5 King 7
Queen takes E5 recount your opening
versus Alexa Yenko from the first half
of the 2020 candidates tournament T4
Knight of six c46 and ic3 Bishop B4 F3
D5 A3 Bishop B7
e4d for fe4 stop tell us about a chess
game that made an impression on you
karma kaspar from the world championship
match 1985 kaspora's octopus Knight on
D3 controlled eight squares in the enemy
camp and allowed him to become the world
champion there's an identity five what
squares does it attack F7 D7 C6 C4 D3 F3
G4 G6 stop how do you do this
visualization and chess isn't difficult
for me it just comes naturally
where does crypto come from
honestly I don't know
can you tell me
learn more at coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free crypto when you
sign up and verify your account
[Music]
and we're back here with our final
moments of today's game four coverage of
the 2021 video World Chess Championship
it's a special day today because it is
the birthday of world champion Magnus
Carlson he turns 31 today and he has
brought us some amazing chess in his uh
in his tenure as World chess champion
world number one we think that he'll
probably continue to do that for years
to come and we just wanted to give him
some special stuff that we prepared
um for him
these guys don't know all the contents
of the basket everyone who's been
watching the Harry Mack wrap knows that
there was uh there was some cheese in it
because that pulled in real time but you
guys ready to see Magnus Carlson's gift
basket pulled it together real quickly
so don't judge it absolutely I don't
know what what you guys think about it
so we'll we're gonna shove it over pull
it up reveal a little heavy that's a you
get a lot I put a lot of effort into it
put it here that was a real screen okay
so we got a a birthday basket for Magnus
Carlson we're going to send him uh a
belt from our sponsor grip six remember
our guests are brought to you by grip6
and you can go to
grip6.com chess and get get uh get a
discount with the promo code
um but the real these are actually very
comfortable on the Belt but we also have
uh so he couldn't get a w today on his
birthday so we we got him a w you guys
thoughts on that
he may not be able to buy a win right
now but we can give him a win I think he
will really appreciate the W you'll
really appreciate the W okay so we have
a w here for Magnus okay but just in
case he's not into that we also got him
um a book and some things to draw with
he doesn't need help he doesn't need
help drawing no he's done plenty of that
in wheelchair how do you think Magnus is
as an artist in general drawing
he's a creative chess player so I feel
oh hey
Okay cool so we got him a w right we got
him we got him some grip six stuff
belt and and socks we got him a draw pad
I think chess players are generally
generally great artists I'm the worst
artist in the world hands down no crying
no drawing for you no drawing don't draw
in chest cannot draw in terms of art
can't do it when I was young I learned
how to draw a bird I learned how to draw
different birds I'm actually good at
drawing Birds that's the only thing like
you've never made one for me I'll make
you a bird see for you you get Madness
all this and he's not even here and you
haven't even uh you you you're the next
birthday you know you're a Sagittarius
like Magnus so you didn't think I knew
that I didn't even know that uh we're
also going to give him we got we got um
a bunch of official merchandise from
fide maybe too many mugs so we'll
offload one of them two minutes
um I'm gonna cover some of the words of
this but we saw his reaction yesterday
when he was unhappy about the drug test
so we also got him his own drug test so
now you have an at-home drug test that
you can do Magnus that way you come
prepared with a with a negative test and
you can tell fide you know
um you know that you're not interested
next time and just show them the proof
there you go you got your own drug test
there you go
um as you saw no birthday basket is
complete without an unnecessarily large
amount of cheese
and a nice
um
a nice Rose hibiscus wow
um there you go
so there you go nice little nice Rose
biscuit kind of like a tea in a bottle I
was like what that's like tea in a box
that's not for young
I love some like some very high quality
wine right there all right well we're
probably gonna open it up as soon as
this is crack all right right and then
okay there we go
um we also had um an extra mug around
here for a logo that we designed that um
it's kind of littered in the background
of our of our templates and stuff and
you can Magnus will get an extra cup
there
um and then of course we're gonna send
him
um more than just what you see here we
of course will send him not only the
T-shirt of the world has Championship
but we'll also send him a hoodie
um and and a mug as well of course you
can pick up your own at go.chess.com
merch and get the Hest up before it all
flies off the shelf I've heard that
people are trying to pay more than
retail price for the Hess merge at this
point that's how much they love it Danny
do you think that Magnus will show up to
the World Chess Championship where world
has championships sure if
I can think of that if I had gotten
ah that would have been genius oh man
that is such a genius idea Bobby okay
well we missed that one um but we do in
all seriousness wish the 16th World
chess champion a very happy 31st
birthday seriously he uh is a true
Ambassador for the game
the greatest of all time as far as I'm
concerned Magnus Carlson happy birthday
buddy and uh no jokes aside we are going
to send him all of this stuff so but not
the basket it's pretty nice the
basketball keep I mean I've been looking
for like a nice little hand towel basket
for my bathroom so you think the
target's special right here you think
Maggie's gonna get a shirt before Favi
does uh well we'll see about that Bobby
Bobby you know I'm really I'm feeling
bad about how this all turned out for me
I I'm feeling left out but you guys have
shirts Magnus now has a shirt
yeah I'm the only one okay but you know
what well I'll I'll we'll think about it
then we'll we'll think about it and
maybe
maybe we'll we'll get you we'll get you
one before the show is over so anyway uh
thank you so much to everybody who tuned
in we may not have had a a w yet on the
board but uh I think it's a w every time
every time we're hanging out together
we're getting the wins hanging out
having a lot of fun and at some point
here we're gonna have we're gonna you
know don't miss it at some point it's
gonna happen I believe we are going to
have magic uh on on the 64 Square so all
right to for my for my amazing co-host
yet again Robert Hess you can't spell
Hess without him seriously pick up your
world has championship gear the man
fobia on a car one and bringing us the
insights that that only he can it's
truly a pleasure sitting next to these
two guys thank you so much for being
here oh one final one final thought too
um again the coinbase critical moment
we're gonna say was actually probably in
the opening the fact that Jan played the
Petrov and neutralized neutralized
Magnus with this albeit whether it was a
surprise or not it didn't lead to
something something that Magnus was able
to get anything out of so that's our
coinbase critical moment brought to you
by house of Stockton sponsors we do
appreciate everything that that you did
here with this very nice chess set and
you can pick up your house of Staunton
gear 15 off right now if you use the
promo code chess.com so all right there
it is that's the beautiful chess set
taken in real in real time of of the uh
or it was it was filmed right here in
studio there you go that's where I
should be sitting right there I'm not
sitting there in that video I am I am
sitting here now
um that's magic when you when you when
you film stuff you make things seem
magical
um
make sure you tune in tomorrow everybody
for game five the feed a World Chess
Championship coverage by chess.com
sponsored by coinbase continues and we
will see you then so whether it's a good
night for you right now you're having a
good day this is goodbye goodbye
today more than ever when the world
comes come together to
get a better tomorrow
it's going to be magic
[Music]
magic magic magic with music with
architecture with colors magic with
celebration with your safety From Here
There and Everywhere for six Hollows day
and night join the making of a new world
starting October 1st
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you